Hello, welcome to Smartless. I'm Dan McBride and I've been a fan of this podcast for quite some time. From listening to it multiple times, I've decided there are a few things that we could do to improve this show. One, is fire the three fucking hosts and put me in instead. So I've done that. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
你好，欢迎来到Smartless。我是丹·麦克布莱德，我一直是这个播客的忠实粉丝。听了这么多期之后，我决定我们得做点什么来改进这个节目。第一，解雇那三个混蛋主持人，换我上。所以我已经这么做了。欢迎来到Smartless。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. How's everybody doing? I've been seeing you guys in a long time. Bye. I feel like you last week. Oh, yeah, you saw me last week. No, but I'm like a week goes by. It's a long feels like a long time. I know. Sean, you woke me up this morning. You told me I'd be late for work.
聪明。聪明。聪明。大家好吗？好久没见你们了。再见。我觉得好像上周才见过。哦，对，你上周确实见过我。不，我是说一周过去了。感觉过了好久。我知道。肖恩，你今天早上把我吵醒了。你跟我说我会上班迟到。
That is true. That is also true. So we didn't return the text. But we went out to dinner and at the end, which was so embarrassing, we'll ordered to the wait staff that it was my birthday. That was embarrassing. Everybody in New York. And we at the end, they said, is it any, you know, any, I go, yeah, it's Sean's birthday. And so they brought out a piece of cake with kids. Yeah. So it's not as pretty a bed. It's so boring. It is an old trick that always works It's a fun one. Yeah speaking of birthdays We have an announcement of a really exciting new thing that we want to talk about
那是真的。那也是真的。所以我们没回短信。但我们出去吃了顿饭，最后发生了一件特别尴尬的事，我们跟服务员说今天是我的生日。那太尴尬了。纽约的所有人都听到了。最后他们问，有什么，你知道，有什么吗？我说，对，是肖恩的生日。于是他们端出了一块插着蜡烛的蛋糕。对。所以这招不太高明。太无聊了。这是一个总是管用的老把戏，挺好玩的。对，说到生日，我们有一个非常令人兴奋的新消息要宣布。
Wait, so and that exciting new thing Sean is is there new New podcast with Rex chat. It's called owned with Rex chat Oh good, I can't be chatting with him really briefly around at the end at the end normally when you you're like, I'm out of here. Fuck those guys. Stick around. Yeah. No. Save a little. Save a little bit for the dessert. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hey, I don't know when this is going to air, but something can be tied into the presidential campaign as soon as you see our next guest. Okay. I mean, you just had an announcement yesterday on Twitter that didn't go well, but we're going to give all Ronny D a nice launch right now.
等等，所以那个令人兴奋的新消息，肖恩，是关于雷克斯·查特的新播客吗？叫《Owned with Rex Chat》。哦，太好了，我待会儿再跟他聊。通常在节目最后，你都会说，我走了。去他妈的那些家伙。留下来吧。对。不。留一点。留一点给甜点。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。嘿，我不知道这期什么时候播出，但一旦你们看到我们的下一位嘉宾，就会和总统竞选联系起来。好吧。我的意思是，你昨天在推特上发了一个公告，效果不太好，但我们现在要给罗尼·D一个很好的开场。
How did we get? I don't want to declare who my guest is before him, but how did we get? How did we get old Ivy League, Ron DeSantis in here. I love these guys who are all like, the elite and every single one of these guys are like double degrees from Ivy League colleges, Ted Cruz, the city. Right. All these guys are such clouds. Yeah.
我们是怎么搞的？我不想在嘉宾出场前宣布他是谁，但我们是怎么搞的？我们是怎么把常春藤盟校的老罗恩·德桑蒂斯弄到这儿来的？我喜欢这些家伙，他们都像是精英，而且每个人都从常春藤盟校拿了双学位，泰德·克鲁兹，那个城市。对。这些家伙真是蠢货。对。
Um, anybody else got anything else? Where's can we get to run? I got a couple things, but if you want to get, get out with it. No, go ahead. Let's hear your. I watch. I watch. I want to open stuff on his desktop right now.
嗯，还有人有别的吗？我们能开始聊罗恩了吗？我有几件事，但如果你想，就先说吧。不，你先请。让我们听听你的。我看着。我看着。我现在想打开他桌面上的东西。
I got. No, I wanted to say, what are the thing cold open ideas? No, let's hear it. We were, when Will and I were at dinner, I wanted to show him, was it weight theft still around the table? Oh, fuck. Ron, you're at the cold one, hey, Ron. Just get thirsty, Wade, we're right with you, Mr. D.
我有。不，我想说，冷开场的点子是什么？不，让我们听听。我们，当威尔和我在吃晚饭时，我想给他看，服务员还在桌边吗？哦，该死。罗恩，你在冷开场里，嘿，罗恩。韦德，我们马上就来，D先生。
We were at dinner, and I said, I showed, I wanted to show Will something on Instagram. So he hit search. And when I hit search, all that came up were guys who were bears and dogs. Wait, what's the dog? Big guy. It's like a domesticated animal
我们在吃晚饭，我说，我展示，我想给威尔看Instagram上的东西。所以他点了搜索。当我点搜索时，出来的全是那些熊和狗。等等，什么是狗？大块头。就像一种家养动物。
that people have in their homes. I thought that was a description of a different type of like gay bears and dogs. And so it was if Jay it was unbelievable. And it was just all like big burly dudes and tight-chain shorts. We have just just thought I know that you still have an ass because if you touch one, like if you click on one thing, the algorithm thinks, oh, you must want to see everything is like, no, but you've been with Scotty a very cute bear for years.
人们在家里养的。我以为那是对另一种像男同性恋中的“熊”和“狗”的描述。简直难以置信。全都是那种大块头、穿着紧身短裤的家伙。我们只是，我知道你手机里还有，因为如果你点了一个，算法就会认为，哦，你肯定想看所有的，不，但你和斯科蒂，一只非常可爱的熊，在一起好多年了。
17 years. Yeah. Okay. So why is there still a recent search for fucking hot bear? Wait a minute. Are you honestly asking me like you don't look at pictures of, I don't know, big, breasted, whatever. But he, no, I do not.
17年了。对。那为什么最近的搜索记录里还有“他妈的火辣熊”？等一下。你是在认真问我吗？就好像你不看那些，我不知道，大胸什么的图片一样。但他，不，我真的不看。
And I'm actually embarrassed to say that my, I have a non-existent relationship to porn. I'm, it's very odd. Well, the other one, the other one of the three, three, some is silent. So I do. I'm letting everybody else bury themselves in comments that will either cut or. Well, not a second. No, well, you're not clean on this at all. No, no, it's like, I don't either. I clicked like I clicked like one one time and then the algorithm sends you 10,000 things. So it's like I get 10,000. This is on Instagram. It's not porn. So this
而且我很尴尬地说，我，我和色情片的关系几乎不存在。我，这很奇怪。好吧，三个人里的另一个，三个人是沉默的。所以我看。我让其他人沉浸在评论里，要么剪掉，要么。好吧，不是一秒钟。不，威尔，你在这方面一点也不干净。不，不，就像，我也不看。我点过一次赞，然后算法就给你发一万个东西。所以我得到了一万个。这是在Instagram上。这不是色情片。所以这
is Instagram that he's looking at photographs. Oh, so it's like, God, it's like God it. So my photograph. So in letter. If the image is moving, then that's pornography. If it's still definitely different. But before you make me sound like I'm some kind of a monster will, don't wouldn't you agree that I'm not talking about porn and people's, you know, frequency. Yeah. Now, on my child's life, I can't remember the last time I looked at pornography. Can you say the same thing? I can.
是Instagram，他在看照片。哦，所以就像，天哪，就像天哪。所以我的照片。所以如果是信件。如果图像是移动的，那才是色情。如果是静止的，绝对不同。但在你让我听起来像个怪物之前，威尔，你不觉得我不是在谈论色情片和人们的，你知道，频率吗？对。现在，以我孩子的生命发誓，我不记得上次看色情片是什么时候了。你能说同样的话吗？我可以。
I'm not a, I'm not a big porn guy. Right. But you're an average male who- I have never have been. It's something that's part of the male thing for some weird thing. I know. Yeah. But for some reason, that's just that, part of the male thing for some weird thing. I know. I know. But for some reason, that's just, that switch is just off.
我不是一个，我不是一个看色情片的人。对。但你是一个普通的男性，他——我从来都不是。这是男性特质的一部分，出于某种奇怪的原因。我知道。对。但出于某种原因，那只是，那是男性特质的一部分，出于某种奇怪的原因。我知道。我知道。但出于某种原因，那个开关就是关着的。
But I hear the thing, I don't have a problem with people. Well, first of all, you have to be an adult. I think this is an important distinction that needs to be made. And I think that porn is really fucked with people's perception of what sex is. Sex is. It's 100%. Yeah, when kids are looking at it, but I looked at it when I was a kid and I didn't think that every sex session is like.
但我听到了，我不反对人们。好吧，首先，你必须是个成年人。我认为这是一个需要做出的重要区分。而且我认为色情片真的搞乱了人们对性是什么的认知。性是什么。百分之百。对，当孩子们看它的时候，但我小时候也看过，我并不认为每一次性行为都像那样。
No, but it was different back then. Right. Just having this conversation because I've had this conversation with my kids and because with the older kids because they can find anything. Well, because the internet is so readily available and I'm not kidding when I say I sat them down and I said, guys, here's the deal. It's going to be, it's incredibly readily available. And I'm not kidding when I say, I sat them down and I said, guys, here's the deal. It's gonna be, it's, you might see me in one or two of them.
不，但那时候不一样。对。只是进行这次谈话，因为我和我的孩子们进行过这次谈话，因为和年龄较大的孩子，因为他们什么都能找到。好吧，因为互联网太容易获取了，我没开玩笑，我让他们坐下来，我说，伙计们，情况是这样的。它会，它非常容易获取。我没开玩笑，我让他们坐下来，我说，伙计们，情况是这样的。它会，它，你可能会在其中一两个里看到我。
Right, yeah. As much as your mom and I, you know, monitor and look at what you guys look at online, which we do with, with a fair bit of frequency, we look at stuff, we have, part of the deal with them having devices is we get to look at messages, whenever we want and get to look at what they're looking at. And that's just, and it's just the way it is.
对，是的。尽管你妈妈和我，你知道，监控并查看你们在网上看的东西，我们确实，相当频繁地，我们看东西，我们和他们达成协议的一部分是，他们有设备，我们就可以随时查看信息，查看他们在看什么。这就是，这就是事实。
And so they know that. You get some of the good sites. Is that what you get? Yeah. And so, so I made sure to tell them that like, look, there's gonna be moments where we can't, there's nothing I can do about it. And you're gonna have access to this stuff.
所以他们知道这一点。你得到了一些好的网站。是这样吗？对。所以，所以我确保告诉他们，看，会有一些时刻，我们无法，我对此无能为力。你们会接触到这些东西。
And you need to know that it is not a good representation of what sex is, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera, for all the pitfalls of. Right. And it was awkward. I mean, it was a tough conversation, but I felt like I had to do it. And of course, like any other human,
你需要知道它并不能很好地代表性是什么，等等，等等，等等，关于所有的陷阱。对。这很尴尬。我的意思是，这是一次艰难的谈话，但我觉得我必须这样做。当然，像任何其他人一样，
of course I've seen pornography. It's just not a porn's not a big part of my experience. It's just not my thing, but it's part of it. So we got it. There we go. No, not a big one part of it. Let's move on to Sanders. Okay, here we go. This guy, it's not really, it's not really Rondis and Dess. He's one of my favorite actors. He's one of my favorite writers. He's been in some of my favorite films and television shows, and some of them he even co-created or fully created himself.
我当然看过色情片。只是色情片不是我经历的重要部分。这只是不是我的菜，但它是它的一部分。所以我们明白了。就是这样。不，不是重要的一部分。让我们继续聊桑德斯。好的，我们开始吧。这家伙，他不是真的，他不是真的罗恩·德桑蒂斯。他是我最喜欢的演员之一。他是我最喜欢的编剧之一。他出演过我最喜欢的一些电影和电视节目，其中一些甚至是他自己联合创作或完全创作的。
Well. Doesn't live in Hollywood, so cool it on the coastal elite bonding session. Right. You're going to have to meet him where he is, fellas, which is right there at the top of Mount Fanny. He's the king of cool, the mayor of LaFland, and definitely the guy you most like to work with next. Are my intros the best? He's married to a Gia, and they've created an Ava and a Declan. Please welcome Georgia Zone, Mr. Daniel Richard McBride. Danny. It's me, Ron DeCentes. Hey, buddy.
好吧。不住在好莱坞，所以别再搞什么沿海精英联谊会了。对。伙计们，你们得去他所在的地方见他，就在范妮山顶。他是酷之王，拉夫兰市长，绝对是你接下来最想合作的人。我的开场白是不是最棒的？他娶了吉亚，他们生了艾娃和德克兰。请欢迎乔治亚州的丹尼尔·理查德·麦克布莱德先生。丹尼。是我，罗恩·德桑蒂斯。嘿，伙计。
Good luck. Oh, my God. What, what, what can did you pop? Was that a beer? It couldn't be further from a beer. It's a pineapple waterloo. Oh, boy. You could drink a beer because you're east coast right now, right?
祝你好运。天哪。什么，什么，你开了什么？那是啤酒吗？离啤酒远着呢。是菠萝味的滑铁卢气泡水。哦，天哪。你可以喝啤酒，因为你现在在东海岸，对吧？
So you have a lunch beer. Yeah, it's after 12. It's 12.43. So that's technically okay. That's that's within the realm of possibly. Yeah, yeah. And we're in North Carolina. I am in South Carolina. I'm in Charleston, South Carolina. Yeah, love me some Charleston.
所以你喝了午餐啤酒。对，过了12点了。现在是12点43分。所以这在技术上是可以的。这，这在可能的范围内。对，对。我们在北卡罗来纳州。我在南卡罗来纳州。我在南卡罗来纳州的查尔斯顿。对，我爱死查尔斯顿了。
I got to have some house out there in South Carolina. Look at that background. Nice depth down there. What is happening? Danny McBride. What's up, man? Thanks you all for having me on here. This is happening. Danny McBride. What's up, man? Thank you all for having me on here. This is incredible. Yeah. But I'm doing it. First of all, alien covenant. One of my favorites. Let's start there. Go ahead, Sean. I love it. I can't believe I, but I can't believe I've never met you. I'm a huge fan. That's some of my bad. I mean, he's not out here. He's, he's hiding in Charleston, keeping it all the Halloween movies that you wrote.
我在南卡罗来纳州得有个房子。看看那个背景。那里的深度不错。发生了什么？丹尼·麦克布莱德。怎么了，伙计？谢谢你们邀请我来这里。这正在发生。丹尼·麦克布莱德。怎么了，伙计？谢谢你们邀请我来这里。这太不可思议了。对。但我正在做。首先，《普罗米修斯》。我最喜欢的电影之一。我们从那儿开始吧。继续，肖恩。我喜欢它。我不敢相信我，但我不敢相信我从来没见过你。我是你的超级粉丝。那是我的错。我的意思是，他没在这儿。他，他躲在查尔斯顿，保留着你写的所有《月光光心慌慌》电影。
I like a massive, massive fan. Oh, thank you so much. That's hiding in trials and keeping it all the Halloween movies that you wrote. Like a massive, massive fan. Oh, thank you so much. That's a big. That's a big. The first time I saw you was in foot fist way. Yeah. Blooming the F away still holds up such a funny mother fuck. Have you shown Archie and Abel that film? No, you know what?
我像是一个超级，超级粉丝。哦，非常感谢。那是大的。那是大的。我第一次见到你是在《拳脚之路》。对。那部电影现在看起来依然很棒，真是个搞笑的混蛋。你给阿奇和阿贝尔看过那部电影吗？不，你知道吗？
I need to show a great friend. I need to show a great friend. What is it? I just saw Jody recently. Did he tell you that? J I just saw Jody recently. Did he tell you that? Jody Hill. Jody Hill.
我需要展示一个好朋友。我需要展示一个好朋友。是什么？我最近刚见过乔迪。他告诉你了吗？我最近刚见过乔迪。他告诉你了吗？乔迪·希尔。乔迪·希尔。
And we worked together briefly on this commercial a couple months ago. I told him to say hello. I bet you he didn't. He kept that for himself. You know, he doesn't want my head to get too greedy. Yeah. I told him to say, I do. And but we were talking about foot fistway.
我们几个月前在这个广告上短暂合作过。我让他问候你。我敢打赌他没说。他自己留着了。你知道，他不想让我的头变得太贪婪。对。我告诉他要说，我确实。而且，但我们当时在谈论《拳脚之路》。
And I love that movie so much and I wish you could tell us a little bit about how that came about. Because I was just so curious. Do yourself a favor and check that out. I'm sorry, I haven't seen it. Sean, you're gonna fucking love it. Walk us through it, Danny.
我太喜欢那部电影了，我希望你能告诉我们一点它是怎么来的。因为我太好奇了。帮自己一个忙，去看看吧。抱歉，我没看过。肖恩，你会他妈的喜欢它的。带我们了解一下，丹尼。
It does. It was one of the first things that I ever did. Jody and myself went to film school together back in North Carolina. And we were living out in Los Angeles for a few years. He was like working on the writing staff of like road rules. I was doing this. Uh, road rules. He had the best job out of all of us.
确实。那是我做过的第一件事之一。乔迪和我一起在北卡罗来纳州读电影学校。我们在洛杉矶住了几年。他当时在《公路规则》的编剧组工作。我在做这个。呃，《公路规则》。他是我们所有人里工作最好的。
Yeah, writing staff on road rules. Yeah, somebody's got to put all that together. Sure. He was doing it. Amazing. And I was a cameraman at the time. I was out there at the time. I was out there like doing this thing called motion control
对，《公路规则》的编剧组。对，总得有人把这一切整合起来。当然。他在做。太棒了。我当时是个摄影师。我当时在那儿。我当时在那儿做这个叫运动控制的东西，
that now it's been replaced by computers. But you know those Ken Burns documentaries where there's photographs and it like pushes and pulls out. That used to be done by hand, my hand. And so I used to do behind the music, history, channel, dog town and Z-boys, that documentary, I worked on all of that stuff. But it wasn't what we had come out to LA to do,
现在已经被电脑取代了。但你知道那些肯·伯恩斯的纪录片吗，里面有照片，它会推近和拉远。那以前是手工完成的，我的手。所以我以前做《音乐背后》、历史频道、《狗镇和滑板少年》，那部纪录片，我参与了所有这些东西。但那不是我们来洛杉矶要做的，
to fill, to fill, still photographs. Yeah, that wasn't your goal, wasn't your goal to go and shoot photographs. Still photographs. Why not? Camera on a slider on a lock off and his push. Yeah.
去填充，去填充，静止照片。对，那不是你的目标，不是你去拍照片的目标。静止照片。为什么不呢？相机放在滑轨上，锁定，然后推近。对。
Wow. I didn't get it, Danny. You need a little slower, please. Got it. That is what it was every day. But easier than working with actors. Uh huh. Yes.
哇。我没听懂，丹尼。你需要慢一点，拜托。明白了。每天都是这样。但比和演员一起工作容易。嗯哼。是的。
So Jody and I were out there for a few years in Los Angeles. And yeah, we wrote that script together and then went back to North Carolina and shot it for like 70 grand and wow. It got into like the midnight screenings at Sundance and then yeah, Will Ferrell and Adam McKay saw it and then they picked it up and then basically just like changed all of our lives like, you know, within months of that being at Sundance, we sold Eastbound and down. We had, you know, got into like, will I work with you on Hot Rod? That was the very first real paycheck I got was that.
所以乔迪和我在洛杉矶待了几年。然后，是的，我们一起写了那个剧本，然后回到北卡罗来纳州，花了大约7万块钱拍了它，哇。它进入了圣丹斯电影节的午夜场，然后，是的，威尔·法瑞尔和亚当·麦凯看到了它，然后他们买下了它，然后基本上就像改变了我们所有人的生活，你知道，在圣丹斯电影节之后几个月内，我们卖掉了《体育老师笑传》。我们，你知道，进入了，威尔，我和你在《热血大叔》里合作过。那是我拿到的第一笔真正的工资。
And then Jason, I think I saw you in the audience at Tropic Thunder, right? Did it not cross pass with you there? Yes, sir. Yeah. And we, and we weren't in the scene together and up in the air, but we're both in that film. Yes, yes.
然后杰森，我想我在《热带惊雷》的观众席里见过你，对吧？我们在那儿没擦肩而过吗？是的，先生。对。而且我们在《在云端》里没有对手戏，但我们都在那部电影里。是的，是的。
Um, I auditioned for that same part, Jason. Seriously, I really did. In up in the air? Yeah. No way. For Jason's part? Yeah. That's so awesome. Have you ever, is this the first time you're revealing this?
嗯，我试镜了同一个角色，杰森。说真的，我真的试了。《在云端》？对。不可能。杰森的角色？对。太棒了。这是你第一次透露这个吗？
Yes. I think so. I've never heard that before. Killing, let's just see how different the character would be. Jake, do the line and then Sean, let's see your, okay. Try, go ahead. Jake, do you remember any dialogue? George, we're going to have to let the character would be. Jake, do the light and then Sean, let's see your okay. Go ahead. Jake, do you remember any dialogue? George, we're gonna have to let you go.
是的。我想是这样。我以前从没听说过。杀手，让我们看看这个角色会有多不同。杰克，念那句台词，然后肖恩，让我们看看你的，好的。试一下，继续。杰克，你还记得任何台词吗？乔治，我们得让这个角色会是什么样。杰克，念那句台词，然后肖恩，让我们看看你的，好的。继续。杰克，你还记得任何台词吗？乔治，我们得让你走。
Good. George, we're gonna have to let you go. Okay, so now I'm kind of seeing, I'm kind of seeing the difference, right, it's a different take for sure. It's a whole different thing. It's a different one. It was a comedy when Sean read for it.
好。乔治，我们得让你走。好的，所以现在我有点看出来了，我有点看出来了区别，对吧，这绝对是不同的演绎。完全是另一回事。是不同的。肖恩读的时候是一部喜剧。
It's a different one. Yeah, they swish genres. All right, now, so Danny, first of all, listener, foot fist way, if you like, if you like films about a Wiley Dojo owner, get in there and watch that. Well, my buddy, my buddy Eli, when we were working together, Eli was a friend of the podcast, and we were working with Jody. Eli kept going off about full-fouced weight because he kept saying,
是不同的。对。他们转换了类型。好了，现在，丹尼，首先，听众们，《拳脚之路》，如果你喜欢，如果你喜欢关于一个狡猾的道场老板的电影，进去看看吧。好吧，我的哥们，我的哥们伊莱，当我们一起工作时，伊莱是播客的朋友，我们和乔迪一起工作。伊莱一直喋喋不休地谈论《拳脚之路》，因为他一直说，
I just love Mal Karate so much. He's like, and Eli's like, I just grew up in Halifax, we had Mal Karate, I grew up on Mal Karate. And when it stopped saying Mal Karate, but that movie was really such a testament to, to a couple of dudes who were really talented, who were like, you know what?
我太喜欢“马尔空手道”了。他说，伊莱说，我就是在哈利法克斯长大的，我们有马尔空手道，我是看着马尔空手道长大的。当它不再说马尔空手道时，但那部电影真的是对两个非常有才华的家伙的证明，他们就像，你知道吗？
This is by the way kind of like pre, what, I hate the term content, but pre sort of content, pre people making YouTube videos and having access to do whatever the fuck they want. You guys want an actually made a movie. You didn't just make like a 30 second video where you say something snarky or dumb. You actually wrote a movie and did it, which I- And it wasn't, yeah, and it was kind of a high-wire act because- Fuck yeah. No one's asking for a laugh in that movie.
顺便说一句，这有点像前，什么，我讨厌“内容”这个词，但前某种内容，前人们制作YouTube视频并有权做任何他们想做的事。你们这些家伙真的拍了一部电影。你们不只是拍了一个30秒的视频，说些刻薄或愚蠢的话。你们真的写了一部电影并拍了出来，这我——而且它不是，是的，这有点像走钢丝，因为——他妈的对。没人要求那部电影里有笑声。
You're playing a guy who's real tough to like on- So committed, so committed. Yeah, you just never winked once and it started this sort of you own this, this ability to be just repulsive but incredibly likable and, and, and, and people give you a pass. Like, do you have any idea what that secret sauce is of, of, of being a, a lovable dick? I have no clue.
你扮演一个很难让人喜欢的家伙——如此投入，如此投入。对，你一次都没眨眼，它开启了这种你拥有的能力，既令人反感又极其讨人喜欢，而且，而且，而且人们原谅了你。就像，你知道这种“可爱的混蛋”的秘方是什么吗？我一点头绪都没有。
Oh good, I was for Danny, shit. So glad the question was for Danny. Yeah. You know, I don't know. I think with all this stuff that we've kind of mind whether it's like foot fistway or even Eastbound, I think it's just the fact that we just try to make sure that the character is, you know, feels real
哦，太好了，我本来是问丹尼的，该死。很高兴这个问题是问丹尼的。你知道，我不知道。我想我们挖掘的所有这些东西，无论是《拳脚之路》还是《体育老师笑传》，我想这只是因为我们尽量确保角色，你知道，感觉真实，
and has dimensions. So that like, you're, it's not just throwing out dickish behavior for dickish behavior, but there's underneath of it, you can kind of see some dimension and maybe understand a little bit where it's coming from, you know, there's more to digest. It's usually a lovingly ignorant
并且有维度。所以，你，这不仅仅是为了混蛋行为而表现出混蛋行为，但在它之下，你可以看到一些维度，也许能理解它来自哪里，你知道，有更多的东西可以消化。它通常是一种可爱的无知，
or uneducated or something that kind of allows for it, right? It's not, you're not being hateful. Well, I think that probably, I don't know, Danny, correct me if I'm wrong or if you disagree with this, but I think that there is that notion of, like I said before, when you're so committed to the character, as long as you stay committed to it, and like you say, and you can't ever,
或者没受过教育，或者某种允许它存在的东西，对吧？它不是，你不是在表现得可恨。好吧，我想那可能，我不知道，丹尼，如果我错了或者你不同意这一点，请纠正我，但我认为有那种概念，就像我之前说的，当你对角色如此投入时，只要你保持投入，就像你说的，而且你永远不能，
people accuse me all the time of playing assholes. I'm like, I don't see them as assholes. I see them as pretty flawed. Yeah, they're just flawed and their sense of what their sense of reality is different from other people's, but they're committed to it. 100%. And they're broken. And I think there's a similarity there. I think that you tap into that. These are characters that are broken. Like, yeah, he's not just being a dick. He's a dick in this moment because shit happened to him that made him act this. And there's a necessary dumbness there, right?
人们总是指责我扮演混蛋。我说，我不认为他们是混蛋。我认为他们相当有缺陷。对，他们只是有缺陷，他们对现实的感知与其他人不同，但他们致力于此。百分之百。而且他们破碎了。我认为这里有相似之处。我认为你利用了这一点。这些角色是破碎的。就像，是的，他不仅仅是在表现得像个混蛋。他在这一刻是个混蛋，因为发生在他身上的烂事让他这样做了。而且有一种必要的愚蠢，对吧？
Because if you were smarter, you'd be nicer. And I always care. Yes, that's right. You'd fake it. You know, and some of it just comes from too, when we were writing, you know, we would try to write scripts that where the protagonist
因为如果你更聪明，你会更友善。我总是关心。是的，没错。你会装出来的。你知道，其中一些也来自于，当我们写作时，你知道，我们会尝试写剧本，主角
was friendly or had like, you know, noble instincts. And it always would just take the script down so, you know, like predictable pass. And when you start aligning the movie behind the back, what would typically be the bad guy in the story, it just suddenly becomes more interesting. There's like more to do do and you confuse the fuck out of the audience too when they're not sure if you should be celebrating this person or what you're trying to do. Now, what about when have you written despicable characters and given them to other people to play and just like what is that process like for you? Where, because so much of what you write
是友好的或者有，你知道，高尚的本能。它总是会把剧本带向，你知道，可预测的道路。当你开始把电影对准故事中通常是坏人的角色时，它突然变得更有趣了。有更多的事情要做，而且当观众不确定是否应该庆祝这个人或者你试图做什么时，你也会把他们搞得一头雾水。现在，当你写过卑鄙的角色并把它们交给别人去演时，那是什么感觉？因为你写的大部分内容
is dependent on how you perform it to make that combination palatable, right? So how do you enjoy that process of giving it over to someone else? I think it's pretty fun. I mean, like what we'll do even on like, you know, the righteous gemstones, which, you know, that new new season coming out here very soon very
都取决于你如何表演它来使那种组合变得可口，对吧？所以你如何享受把它交给别人的过程？我觉得这很有趣。我的意思是，就像我们甚至在，你知道，《义理宝石》上做的那样，你知道，新的一季很快就要出来了，非常
18 June 18th right just gemstones max what max I Think sometimes you know with that a lot of characters and that are on savory and I think it's like We'll try to find the comedy in the behavior as opposed to like a punchline So that like the actor could really get their head around behavior where like the delivery of a specific line is open to interpretation. But it kind of feels like when we really get in there with bringing anybody into our circle,
6月18日，对吧，《义理宝石》，Max，什么，Max，我想有时，你知道，那里面有很多角色是不讨喜的，我想就像我们会尝试在行为中寻找喜剧，而不是像笑话梗。这样演员就能真正理解行为，其中特定台词的表达方式是开放的。但当我们要把任何人带入我们的圈子时，感觉就像，
if the behavior makes sense, then I feel like a lot of people can step in. Is that where you think people go wrong the most is getting that backwards? I think so. I think sometimes you try to be shocking with what a character says, but I think to try to figure out what a character does and make that more shocking is kind of more interesting. You know what I was fine when you get into, when you write characters like that and you
如果行为说得通，那么我觉得很多人都能加入。你认为人们在这一点上最容易出错吗？我想是这样。我想有时你试图用角色说的话来制造冲击，但我认为试图弄清楚角色做什么并让那更具冲击力更有趣。你知道，当我发现当你写那样的角色时，你
work on things where on the page they seem super unlikable. We always, Jay, we used to talk about this all the time when we were making rest of the development, which is the writers would do a really amazing job of making these characters despicable and funny, but it was always our job to try and make them likable to kind of counteract that. And that's, and if you look that out on the page,
在纸面上看起来超级不可爱的作品上工作。我们总是，杰，我们在制作《发展受阻》时经常谈论这个，那就是编剧们在让这些角色卑鄙又好笑方面做得非常出色，但我们的工作总是试图让他们变得讨人喜欢，以抵消这一点。而且那是，如果你在纸面上看，
you'd be like, fuck, what, there's nothing, this character sucks, like this guy's a total dick. And I've noticed in other things that I've worked on something I just wrote recently, where you're like, trust me, I know that on the page it looks like X, it's gonna be Y. But if you just read it in a vacuum, right? And I imagine on gemstones, it must be like that. If you read a bunch of those scripts,
你会说，该死，什么，什么都没有，这个角色太烂了，这家伙是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。我注意到我在其他作品中工作时，我最近写的东西，你会说，相信我，我知道在纸面上它看起来像X，它会是Y。但如果你只是在真空中阅读它，对吧？我想在《义理宝石》上，一定也是这样。如果你读了一堆那些剧本，
you'd be like, what the fuck, man? These guys are dicks. But it's also so reliant on like, you got Adam Devine and John Goodman in there who really know exactly what we're talking about, how to do it so well, play these deeply flawed, broken people that end up being, you know, really lovable. Danny, let me ask you this,
你会说，搞什么鬼，伙计？这些家伙是混蛋。但这也非常依赖于，你有亚当·迪凡和约翰·古德曼在里面，他们真的非常清楚我们在说什么，如何做得那么好，扮演这些深度破碎、有缺陷的人，最终变得，你知道，非常可爱。丹尼，让我问你这个，
because I've mentioned this a few times, and I think that you're starting to follow it. I think you're already in this category. I maintain that John Goodman has never turned in a bad performance in his life. And he's been in some bad movies. Sure, everybody has. He's never turned in a bad performance. He hasn't.
因为我提过几次，而且我认为你已经开始关注了。我认为你已经在这一类里了。我坚持认为约翰·古德曼一生中从未有过糟糕的表演。他演过一些烂电影。当然，每个人都有。他从未有过糟糕的表演。他没有。
He's awesome. And I mean, we're always like blown away that we get to work with him, but you know, you just look back and I mean, he was making TV shows, you know, when TV wasn't even cool and he was still able to show up in the Cohen brothers and remember him and revenge in the nerds. Yes. Wow. Dude, dude, revenge in the nerds, he's the coach and he goes, he goes, you got beat and he takes his hat off and he goes, buy a bunch of birds.
他太棒了。我的意思是，我们总是像被震撼了一样，我们能和他一起工作，但你知道，你回顾一下，我的意思是，他在制作电视节目，你知道，当电视还没那么酷的时候，他仍然能在科恩兄弟的电影里出现，还记得他在《书呆子的复仇》里吗？是的。哇。伙计，伙计，《书呆子的复仇》，他是教练，他说，他说，你被击败了，他摘下帽子说，买一堆鸟。
And it's one of the funniest, to me, it's one of the funniest readings of a line a whole lot of time, because he's talking about nerds. Yeah, so mad that he takes his hat off and throws it. That's really funny. And we will be right back. Smartless is sponsored by Smart Water.
对我来说，这是很长一段时间里最有趣的台词解读之一，因为他在谈论书呆子。对，他太生气了，以至于他摘下帽子扔了出去。那真的很有趣。我们马上回来。Smartless由Smart Water赞助。
So, you know, when you're acting on stage for a long time, and you sweat, and you sweat, and you sweat, that's what happened to me, and I came home the other day, and I was had a massive headache, and I was like, what the heck's going on? It's got to say, what's wrong? I was like, nothing! And I got really kind of like short and angry,
所以，你知道，当你在舞台上表演很长时间时，你会出汗，你会出汗，你会出汗，这就是发生在我身上的事，我前几天回家，我头痛欲裂，我就想，到底怎么回事？它得说，怎么了？我说，没什么！我变得有点像，简短而愤怒，
and he's like, what's your deal? was like, nothing. And I got really kind of like short and angry. And he's like, what's your deal? And I was like, I don't know. He's like, are you hydrated? Like, seriously? He was like, are you hydrated? I just thought you, because I was standing there drenched after I came home from work. And I was like, maybe that's why I have a headache.
他说，你怎么了？我说，没什么。我变得有点像，简短而愤怒。他说，你怎么了？我说，我不知道。他说，你补水了吗？真的吗？他说，你补水了吗？我只是以为你，因为我下班回家后站在那儿浑身湿透。我就想，也许这就是我头痛的原因。
Maybe that's why I'm cranky. So I downed smart water. Cause that's what we have here in the house. And it worked. And I became a hyd-mahedic one-way. Sometimes you just don't need aspirin, sometimes you just need water. Here on the podcast, we are smartless, but not smart waterless. Smart water is 100% vapor distilled with a pure crisp taste. It's pH-balanced and offers added electrolytes for taste.
也许这就是我脾气暴躁的原因。所以我喝了Smart Water。因为那是我们家里有的。它奏效了。我变成了一个补水的人。有时你只是不需要阿司匹林，有时你只需要水。在这里，在播客上，我们是Smartless，但不是没有Smart Water。Smart Water是100%蒸汽蒸馏的，口感纯净清脆。它酸碱平衡，并添加了电解质以增加口感。
And here's a little tidbit. When I'm done drinking my smart water, I fill it up with regular water from the faucet, and then I water my plants around my apartment here in New York. And when people are over and they see me do that, they think, boy, he must want his plants to drink that premium high quality water. It says here, we're not allowed to say
这里有一个小花絮。当我喝完我的Smart Water时，我用自来水把它装满，然后我给我在纽约公寓里的植物浇水。当人们过来看到我这样做时，他们会想，天哪，他一定想让他的植物喝那种优质的高质量水。这里写着，我们不允许说
that smart water makes you smarter, but we can say it's for sipping while you're listening to your favorite podcast, of course. Keep it smart with smart water. We're brought to you in part by Zip Recruiter. You know, I have a lesser known talent than a lot of people know. I can cook stuff. I'm not like lot of people know. I can cook stuff. I'm not like a great chef,
Smart Water让你更聪明，但我们可以说它适合在你听最喜欢的播客时啜饮，当然。用Smart Water保持聪明。我们部分由Zip Recruiter带给您。你知道，我有一个比很多人知道的更不为人知的才华。我会做饭。我不是，很多人知道。我会做饭。我不是一个伟大的厨师，
but I will make stuff that will blow your mind and like, for example, sloppy joes. I have the greatest old school sloppy joe recipe that I'm gonna keep at secret. But it's a lot of work. It has like tons of ingredients and stuff in it that you don't, it's not just from a can, like I make it from scratch people.
但我会做一些让你大吃一惊的东西，比如，乔氏三明治。我有一个最棒的老派乔氏三明治食谱，我会保密。但这需要很多工作。它有大量的配料和东西，你不知道，它不仅仅是来自罐头，就像我是从零开始做的，伙计们。
So I just wanted to say from like soft skills to hard skills like sloppy Joe making, it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful, especially if you're going to open a restaurant of sloppy Joe's. If you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open roles, you need Zippercrooter. And right now you can try it for free at zippercrooter.com slash smartless. How does Zippercrooter find the most spot on people for your roles? Zippercrooter uses powerful technology to find and send you people whose skills and experience
所以我只是想说，从软技能到硬技能，比如做乔氏三明治，需要各种各样的才能才能使企业成功，特别是如果你要开一家乔氏三明治餐厅。如果你正在招聘，并且想为你的空缺职位找到合适的人才组合，你需要Zip Recruiter。现在你可以免费试用，网址是zippercruiter.com/smartless。Zip Recruiter如何为你的职位找到最合适的人选？Zip Recruiter使用强大的技术来寻找并向你发送那些技能和经验
match your job. If you see someone you're really interested in, Zippercrooter lets you easily invite them to apply to your job to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does. No wonder 3.3 million businesses have come to Zippercruder for their hiring needs. Tap into Zippercruder's unmatched talent for finding great candidates. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercruder 4-free zippercruder.com slash smartless.
与你的工作匹配的人。如果你看到你非常感兴趣的人，Zip Recruiter让你轻松邀请他们申请你的工作，以增加你在竞争对手之前获得他们的机会。难怪330万家企业来到Zip Recruiter寻求招聘需求。利用Zip Recruiter在寻找优秀候选人方面无与伦比的才能。五分之四在Zip Recruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主在第一天内就得到了高质量的候选人。亲自看看吧。去这个独家网址免费试用Zip Recruiter zippercruiter.com/smartless。
Again, that's zippercruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. This episode of Smartless is brought to you in part by Fandool. Take your first swing at betting MLB on Fandool and get 10 times your first bet amount in bonus bets up to $200. That's right, just bet 20 bucks and you'll land $200 in bonus bets when are lose. That's 200 you can spend betting everything from the money line to the over under to who
再说一遍，是zippercruiter.com/smartless Zip Recruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。本期Smartless部分由Fandool赞助。在Fandool上进行MLB投注，你的第一笔投注金额可获得10倍的奖励投注，最高可达200美元。没错，只需投注20美元，无论输赢，你都能获得200美元的奖励投注。这200美元你可以花在投注一切上，从胜负盘到大小分，再到你
you think is going to the first home run. All on an app that's safe, secure, and super easy to use. Plus, when you win, you get paid instantly. There's no better place to bet on MLB than Fandool America's number one sports book. So sign up today and visit fandool.com slash smartless to get up to $200 in bonus bets. That's fandool.com slash smartless.
认为谁会打出第一个本垒打。都在一个安全、可靠且超级易用的应用程序上。此外，当你赢了，你会立即获得报酬。没有比Fandool更好的MLB投注场所了，它是美国第一大体育博彩公司。所以今天就注册并访问fandool.com/smartless，获得最高200美元的奖励投注。那是fandool.com/smartless。
Fandool, official partner of Major League Baseball. 21 plus exclusions apply. I see show notes for Fall Disclaimer. And now, back to the show. So Danny, without revealing any names, was there a super duper dick that you grew up with? It's just like, made you laugh or that you kind of model some of this brand of humor as per your own names?
Fandool，美国职业棒球大联盟的官方合作伙伴。21岁以上，适用排除条款。查看节目说明以获取Fandool免责声明。现在，回到节目。所以丹尼，在不透露任何名字的情况下，你成长过程中有没有一个超级混蛋？就像，让你发笑或者你把这种幽默感作为你自己名字的一部分？
Or revealing names. Or you can reveal them. I don't think it was anyone in particular, but you know, Jody grew up in North Carolina. I grew up in Virginia. And both of us went to a minute film school and an art school. And so I think we were both these kind of guys that grew up in the South, but didn't necessarily like kind
或者透露名字。或者你可以透露它们。我不认为有特别的人，但你知道，乔迪在北卡罗来纳州长大。我在弗吉尼亚州长大。我们俩都去了电影学校和艺术学校。所以我认为我们俩都是那种在南方长大，但不一定像
of fit the mold of like what a lot of our neighbors were about. And we would kind of find humor in it instead of like participating. And so I think once we got to school, we just sort of like just swap stories. And you know, Jody worked in a Taikwondo studio. I took ancient Rukurati and we like our our senseys were basically like the same person when we kind of described the weird shit that he used to do. And we just had a lot of I think there was a lot of crossover in the type of people
我们很多邻居那样符合那种模式的家伙。我们会在其中寻找幽默，而不是参与其中。所以我认为一旦我们到了学校，我们只是交换故事。而且，你知道，乔迪在跆拳道馆工作。我学了古代空手道，我们，我们的教练基本上是同一个人，当我们描述他过去做的那些奇怪的事情时。我们只是有很多，我认为在我们成长的周围人中有很多交叉。所以然后我们只是。而且对于特雷西，乔迪是。乔迪·希尔。乔迪·希尔，和你一起写、创作了《体育老师笑传》，对吧？是的。对。对。也是编剧。
when he grew up around. And so then we just. And for Tracy, Jody is. Jody Hill. Jody Hill who wrote, created a Eastbound with you, right? Yes. Yeah. Yeah, writer as well.
是的。好吧，你提出了一个有趣的部分。如果我可以一次，丹尼，所以你在南方长大，你对那些可能与你的邻居不同的东西感兴趣，这是一种非常好的表达方式。但那是什么样的经历？作为两个喜剧演员，而且正如你所说，不一定符合那种模式的家伙，那是什么样的经历？
Yeah. Well, you brought up an interesting part. Just if I could for once, Danny, so you grew up in the South and that you were interested in stuff that was maybe different from what your neighbors, which is a really great way to put it. But what was that experience like? As two guys who are comedians and who are, as you say, don't necessarily fit that mold, what was that experience like?
某种程度上，你有时会觉得在自己家里是个局外人吗，还是你？你知道，当我还是个孩子时，我不认为我意识到了那么多。这有点像当我的朋友们开始安定下来或留在我长大的城镇时。你就像，哦，你现在变成了那个家伙，或者你是那个城镇里的那个人。我想当我们还是孩子时，你只会倾向于那些，你知道，我只是太沉迷于电影和电视了，以至于我很多时候都坐在沙发上，只是看租来的电影，通过电视上的乱码信号看HBO。
Sort of, did you feel like an outsider in your own home sometimes or did you? You know, when I was a kid, I don't think I realized it as much. It was sort of like when my friends were like starting to settle down or stay in the town that I grew up in. And you're like, oh, you're becoming that guy now or you're that that fella in the town. I think when we were kids, you would just kind of gravitate towards who kind of, you know, I just was like so into movies and TV that I just sat my ass on the couch a lot of times, just like watching rented movies and watching HBO through a scrambled signal on the TV.
我是一个书呆子。我确实。你是吗？我是，就像，我只是太沉迷了，就像我在五年级时用家用摄像机拍电影。而且，你知道，我过去常常，我们没有有线电视，但我会坐在那儿，我录下了，
And I was a nerd. I did exactly. Were you? I was, like, I was just so in, like, I was like making movies on like a home video camera when I was like in fifth grade. And, you know, I used to, we didn't have cable, but I would like sit there and I recorded,
我记得《天才老爸》在HBO播出时的音频。我们没有它。然后我会戴着随身听骑自行车在社区里转，哦哇。听《天才老爸》。真的吗？不可能。
I remember just the audio of Mr. Mom when it came on HBO. We didn't have it. And then I would ride around the neighborhood on my bike in a walkman like, Oh wow. To Mr. Mom. Really? No way.
太疯狂了。等等，为什么我忘了《天才老爸》？《天才老爸》是迈克尔·基顿的一部伟大的电影。迈克尔·基顿是那部令人难以置信的伟大电影。对，伟大。对。对。他演的那部电影的名字是什么，他去了日本并在一家汽车公司工作。不，他们来到这里。哦，那是对的。抱歉。我也没看过那部。等等，丹尼。你有没有像？我做，我做，迈克尔·基顿，这是我做的唯一的模仿。我爱迈克尔·基顿。我前几天也刚碰到他。
That's wild. Wait, why am I blanking on Mr. Mom? Mr. Mom's an all time great Michael Keith. Michael Keith was the the one believably great movie. Yeah, great. Right. Yeah. He was a name of the movie that he did where he went over to Japan and worked in an auto. No, they came over here. Oh, that's right. Sorry. Didn't see that one either. Wait, daddy. Do you ever like? I do. I do Michael Keaton, it's the only impression I do. I love Michael Keaton. I just ran into him the other day too.
我总是像，等等，你们来到这里是为了听那个自行车汽车公司？听众们，脸，脸在做这件事。你能做什么？这不是声音。是脸。听起来仍然像脸在做很多工作。对。你有没有写过什么东西，写完它，把它给一个演员，然后说，该死，我真希望我能把那个角色留给自己。你知道吗？我没有。我从来没有真正得到。我觉得这都是我的创作。
I'm always like, wait, you guys came over to hear the bike car company? Listener, the face is, is the face is doing it. What can you do in it? It's not the voice. It's the face. It's still sound like what the face is doing a lot of the work. Yeah. Do you ever write something, finish it, give it to an actor, and then go, damn, and I wish I would have kept that part for myself. You know what? I don't. I never really get. I feel like it's all my creation.
我总是想，等等，你们过来是为了听自行车公司的事吗？听众朋友们，表情，表情在起作用。你在里面能做什么？不是声音，是表情。它听起来仍然像是表情在发挥很大作用。是的。你有没有写过什么东西，写完后交给演员，然后心想，该死，我真希望那个角色能留给自己演。你知道吗？我没有。我从来没有那种感觉。我觉得这一切都是我的创作。
And so I'm like, I, I think the parts when I'm in shows that I'm on screen are the parts I enjoy the least. I love watching other people like do it and take it and run with it. That's it. Yeah, it's going to be super satisfying. And then what about when you read something and you go, Oh, I could, I could play this character and you get like a real specific take on it, which I'm, that it's a definition of what you do.
所以我觉得，我在节目中出镜的部分反而是我最不享受的。我喜欢看别人去表演、去发挥。就是这样。是的，这会非常有成就感。那么，当你读到剧本时，你会想“哦，我可以演这个角色”，并且对它有非常具体的理解，这正是你工作的定义。
And then you're not auditioning anymore. So you show up on set and everyone's about to see for the first time who they've hired and what version of this character we're gonna get. And here comes the dynamic bride special. Is there any like, have you, as a director, ever pulled you aside and go, hey man, so like Ridley Scott, for example.
然后你就不再需要试镜了。你出现在片场，大家第一次看到他们雇佣的人，以及我们将呈现出这个角色的什么版本。动态新娘特辑来了。作为导演，有没有人把你拉到一边说，嘿伙计，比如雷德利·斯科特。
Did you read for that or did he know who he was hiring? Yeah, I want you to do something comedic because it's obviously not a comedy. You know, he, I had a meeting with him. He called me in for a meeting and I was like blown away. I mean, I love that franchise and he, you know, is especially. You are so good in that. Yeah, I appreciate that. Thank you.
你是去试镜那个角色，还是他早就知道要雇佣你？是的，他希望我做一些喜剧表演，因为那显然不是一部喜剧。你知道，我和他开过一次会。他叫我去开会，我当时惊呆了。我是说，我喜欢那个系列，而且他，你知道，尤其是。你在那部戏里演得太好了。是的，我很感激。谢谢。
I mean, I was so nervous to go in there because the same thing, I'm like, I don't want to, I like these movies. I don't want to ruin them by being in it. Like when it comes up, it somehow takes people out of it. And he kind of, he was just sort of of on the mindset where he said that, like what he does is he just is the guard rail. He'll, he'll put people in his movies that have a distinct personality. And he just lets them be them.
我是说，我当时去的时候非常紧张，因为同样的原因，我心想，我不想，我喜欢这些电影。我不想因为我的参演而毁了它们。就像当它出现时，它会让人出戏。而他当时的心态是，他说他所做的就是充当护栏。他会把有独特个性的人放进他的电影里，然后让他们做自己。
And then he'll be there in case anybody's going too far off the rails, but you know, the other thing it was awesome about me. Bill Paxton in the first one was a pretty great, right? That's what I kept watching. He was like, he'd build nailed this. He was incredible in this world. And the other thing is he does like everything on that movie was like five cameras at all times.
然后他会在那里，以防有人偏离轨道太远，但你知道，关于他的另一件很棒的事。第一部里的比尔·帕克斯顿演得相当棒，对吧？我一直在看那个。他就像，他把这个角色演活了。他在这个世界里表现得不可思议。还有一件事，他在那部电影里所做的一切，就像是始终保持五台摄像机同时拍摄。
Like every so you it was like two takes of something and then he would move on. It's the only movie I've ever been on that finished like two or three weeks had a schedule. Like every day you'd come in. And if you're like, here's what I'm shooting today. And this is in case we get through this, this is tomorrow's sides. And you would get to it all the time. So when you got on that ship for alien covenant, what was that set like? Is it as cool to be honest as it is to see?
就像每一场戏，所以基本上拍两遍就过了，然后他就会继续下一场。这是我待过的唯一一部比计划提前两三周杀青的电影。就像每天你过来，如果他说，这是我今天要拍的。这是以防我们拍完了这些，这是明天的通告。你总是能按时完成。所以当你登上《异形：契约》的那艘飞船时，那个片场是什么样的？说实话，它看起来和拍出来一样酷吗？
You guys, I mean, I got this one. Hey, Sean, you know they, they're in shooting space, right? Yeah, and they build it. It's on a movie studio. Wait a minute. What single tear? No, it's, it was all built. I mean, you rolled into the sound stage and that, that ship was for real in there. No, walk through every fall of it. You could sit there. And he designs it so the cameras are like hidden within the set. So that's how he can get so many shots in every, like a Ridley Scott movie.
伙计们，我是说，我拿到了这个。嘿，肖恩，你知道他们是在太空拍摄的，对吧？是的，他们把它造了出来。它在一个电影制片厂里。等等。什么？单行泪？不，它是完全搭建出来的。我是说，你走进摄影棚，那艘飞船真的就在那里。不，走过它的每一个角落。你可以坐在那里。他设计的时候让摄像机隐藏在布景里。所以这就是他能在雷德利·斯科特的电影里拍到那么多镜头的原因。
It's not like, you know, only one of the shots is good in the rest or things he'd never use. It's all designed. But for the actors, it was kind of awesome because behind the scenes, everybody was so nervous about the fact that he was only doing like two takes. It's almost like they come prepared as if it's live, theater or something where people just know
并不是说，你知道，只有其中一个镜头是好的，其余的都是他永远不会用的。一切都是设计好的。但对于演员来说，这很棒，因为在幕后，每个人都因为他只拍两遍而感到非常紧张。这就像他们准备得好像是现场直播，戏剧什么的，人们只是知道
that you're not gonna have the ability to kind of find it on the day. You just kind of have to come with it, and then it's gone, you know? That's kind of a great, yeah, that's a great device to keep everybody on their toes a little bit. Yeah, why not? Totally, totally.
你没有能力在当天去寻找感觉。你必须直接带入状态，然后它就结束了，你知道吗？这真是一个让每个人都保持警惕的好方法。是的，为什么不呢？完全同意，完全同意。
I should do that. We should do a comedy space thing, but like full scale like that. Like, you know, like not like space balls was a great movie, but yeah, that was sort of like on on purpose. It kind of was meant to be a little low-fi, a little low tech. But if you did it like on the Ridley Scott scale, no one winking, you know. What if somebody's got something in their eyes? So it looks like they're winking. Then it's a tick. And you need to be sensitive.
我也应该那样做。我们应该做一个太空喜剧，但要像那样全规模的。就像，你知道，不像《太空炮弹》那是一部伟大的电影，但那是故意的。它本意就是有点低保真，有点低科技。但如果你以雷德利·斯科特的规模来做，没有人眨眼，你知道。如果有人眼睛里进了东西呢？看起来像是在眨眼。那是一种抽动。你需要敏感一点。
You're not. Can I ask you a question? Unless Jay, you want to ask that one? This is what it's here for. Yeah, that's what the whole thing is. I'm sorry, but I guess you're still taking questions. Yeah, I'm just sort of a little bit longer. I'll be here.
你不是。我能问你一个问题吗？除非杰伊，你想问那个？这就是它的存在意义。是的，这就是全部内容。抱歉，但我猜你还在接受提问。是的，我只是稍微多待一会儿。我会在这里。
Yeah. Yeah. So wait, so when I was a kid, one of my favorite movies was... It seems less like a question, more like it's just a story. Tell us about yourself. No, when I was a kid, I was obsessed with the movie Halloween. And I watched the making of it, the behind the scenes, and there's this new series on, I don't know,
是的。是的。等等，当我还是个孩子的时候，我最喜欢的电影之一是……这听起来不太像个问题，更像是一个故事。给我们讲讲你自己吧。不，当我还是个孩子的时候，我痴迷于电影《月光光心慌慌》。我看了它的制作特辑，幕后花絮，现在有一个新系列，我不知道，
where they do, like, the revisit, how they made it. Are you just trying to highlight the fact that you had cable and the Danny didn't, because he just said he didn't have cable growing up. Yeah. And now you're talking, I watched behind the scenes. I watched on the other channel. I watched this. No, this is like a fucking...
他们做了回顾，他们是怎么制作它的。你只是想强调你有有线电视而丹尼没有吗，因为他刚才说他小时候没有有线电视。是的。现在你在说，我看了幕后花絮。我在另一个频道看了。我看了这个。不，这简直是个该死的……
This is not a question. This is a fuck you to Danny McBride. No, this is sadly a year ago. Oh, okay. Okay. No, but no, I've always been really into that movie because it was, I grew up on it and it was wild. So the fact that you wrote the newest ones, which are so, you know, I've always been really into that movie because I grew up on it and I was wild. So the fact that you wrote the newest ones,
这不是一个问题。这是对丹尼·麦克布莱德的羞辱。不，这很遗憾是一年前的事了。哦，好吧。好吧。不，但我一直很喜欢那部电影，因为它是，我从小看着它长大，它太狂野了。所以你写了最新几部的事实，它们是如此，你知道，我一直很喜欢那部电影，因为我从小看着它长大，它太狂野了。所以你写了最新几部的事实，
which are so, I have to tell you, when the first one, I saw the trailer for the first one to come out, I was like, oh God, I hope they get this right. It's so important to me and so many fans. And boy, my God, it was amazing. It was incredible how you re-imagined it. And then all three of them.
它们是如此，我必须告诉你，当第一部，我看到第一部的预告片出来时，我心想，天哪，我希望他们能拍好。它对我以及这么多粉丝来说太重要了。天哪，它太棒了。你重新构思它的方式令人难以置信。然后三部都是。
And the last one, I loved. It solved so many things. I loved the whole thing. Yeah, how did that come about? You know, one of the other cohorts that I moved to Charleston with is David Green, who's also a director. Yeah, he did a great job. Right before we moved out of Los Angeles, well, even getting to Charleston, I'll explain
最后一部，我喜欢。它解决了很多事情。我喜欢整个过程。是的，那是怎么发生的？你知道，和我一起搬到查尔斯顿的伙伴之一是大卫·格林，他也是一位导演。是的，他做得很好。就在我们搬离洛杉矶之前，甚至在去查尔斯顿之前，我会解释
that because that has something to do with Halloween. We shot, I'd never really even been to Charleston before. We shot vice principals down here in Charleston and lived here for like six months. Yeah, that's a fantastic show, man. Yeah, thank you. And we all have kids around the same age. Everybody's kids were like between three and five
因为那和《月光光心慌慌》有关。我们拍了，我以前甚至没怎么去过查尔斯顿。我们在查尔斯顿拍了《副校长》，在那里住了大约六个月。是的，那是一部精彩的剧，伙计。是的，谢谢。我们都有差不多大的孩子。每个人的孩子都在三到五岁之间
when we were shooting vice principals. And we were just, we all lived in LA, we were here for like six months, and then we all went back to Los Angeles. And then after a few months, everyone just started sort of like, man, I really miss it down there. Like sometimes I think it would be cool to just like live there.
当我们拍摄《副校长》的时候。我们都住在洛杉矶，我们在这里待了大约六个月，然后我们都回到了洛杉矶。几个月后，每个人都开始觉得，天哪，我真的很想念那里。有时候我觉得住在那里会很酷。
Would you ever, and everyone started talking, and it turned into this thing where like, we ended up as like almost like 10 families, that all the dudes went one weekend to go sus it out, and then the wives went, and then everybody kind of ended up, it was like almost like 10 families that all the dudes went one weekend to go sus it out and then the wives went and then everybody kind of met up we're like, are we gonna do this? So we're gonna move to Charleston with our whole crew and everybody did it and like, it was like six years ago
你会吗，每个人都开始讨论，它变成了一件事，我们最终几乎有10个家庭，所有的男人们在一个周末去考察，然后妻子们去了，然后每个人最终，几乎有10个家庭，所有的男人们在一个周末去考察，然后妻子们去了，然后每个人都聚在一起，我们说，我们要这么做吗？所以我们要带着我们整个团队搬到查尔斯顿，每个人都这么做了，就像六年前
and so part of it was like we need to bring work down here. We need to like try to pump this industry up down here and so Halloween was the first thing we sort of did. David and I signed up for that. We're like, this will be a cool project to bring down there and to get people working. So you shot it there. We shot it here, yeah.
所以其中一部分是我们需要把工作带到这里。我们需要尝试在这里推动这个行业，所以《月光光心慌慌》是我们做的第一件事。大卫和我签了那个项目。我们想，这将是一个带到那里并让人们有工作可做的酷项目。所以你们在那里拍的。我们在那里拍的，是的。
Wow. Yes, so David had been got approached by Jason Blum to see if he was interested in adapting it. And David knew I was a really big fan of it and asked me what I thought. And I had the same kind of reaction as you. I was like, fuck, I just love the series so much that it would suck to create something that diminished it.
哇。是的，所以大卫被杰森·布鲁姆接触，看他是否有兴趣改编它。大卫知道我是它的超级粉丝，问我怎么想。我的反应和你一样。我说，该死，我太喜欢这个系列了，如果创作出削弱它的东西会很糟糕。
And then the more we thought, we're like, well, somebody's gonna do it. So maybe we'll have a better shot of creating it because we really care about it coming out good. I guess anyone would, but- So- Not to out of the park. We just, we had a blast.
然后我们想得越多，我们就想，好吧，总会有人做的。所以也许我们更有机会把它做好，因为我们真的很在乎它出来后的效果。我想任何人都会，但是——所以——没有搞砸。我们只是，我们玩得很开心。
And I think we never thought about the pressure of it Yeah, you know, I guess anyone would but not out of the park. We just we had a blast And I think we never thought about the pressure of it because I feel like I Was sort of my own worst critic on it. I was like, you know I'm always like convinced I'm gonna ruin things that I touched that I didn't all the way So I didn't want to you know, I was so nervous about it I think it didn't really register like the weight of the fans and everything until it premiered at the Toronto Film Festival.
而且我觉得我们从来没想过它的压力。是的，你知道，我想任何人都会，但没有搞砸。我们只是，我们玩得很开心。而且我觉得我们从来没想过它的压力，因为我觉得我对自己要求最严。我总是确信我会毁掉我触碰的东西，如果我没有全程参与的话。所以我不想，你知道，我对此非常紧张。我想直到它在多伦多电影节首映时，我才真正意识到粉丝们的重量和一切。
And when I saw the crowd and the amount of people that were lined up and people in the masks and the shirts, there was just this moment with Dave and I were like, fuck, this doesn't work. We are about to, like this is a rabid fan base and they're going to destroy us. You can get killed by 500 Michael Myers. Oh, that's what I thought. That's what I really thought was going to be. And it was such a gratifying feeling
当我看到人群和排队的人数，还有戴着面具和穿着衬衫的人，那一刻大卫和我心想，该死，如果这不行怎么办。我们即将，这是一个狂热的粉丝群，他们会摧毁我们。你可能会被500个迈克尔·迈尔斯杀死。哦，我就是这么想的。我真的以为会那样。那是一种非常令人满足的感觉
when we screened it there into field the audience in it at the end and there applauding and clad. It was probably one of the coolest moments of anything in my career, that moment there with the fans was so much fun. So what you were saying earlier, you really did the work about the characters because if that's not there, it would have been such a failure.
当我们在那里放映时，在最后感受到观众的反应，他们在鼓掌。这可能是我职业生涯中最酷的时刻之一，那一刻与粉丝在一起太有趣了。所以你刚才说的，你真的在角色上下了功夫，因为如果那部分缺失，那将是一个巨大的失败。
But really like the backstory and the relationships and everything is what made it so great. Yeah, that's what we like love. I think a lot of the stuff we're influenced by is a lot of that 70's cinema, which would be character pieces and not necessarily story driven, but sort of, you know, just pieces around characters that are interesting. And so I think we tried to apply that idea to our take on Halloween
但真的，背景故事、人际关系和一切才是让它如此伟大的原因。是的，这就是我们所热爱的。我认为我们受到的很多影响来自70年代的电影，那些是角色驱动的作品，不一定是以故事为导向，而是围绕着有趣的角色。所以我认为我们尝试将那个想法应用到我们对《月光光心慌慌》的诠释中
and see what we could do with that. So good. What's your, what's your ideal frequency of working? You're down there, you got all your, your friends and colleagues down there. Do you guys like to always have something that you're shooting and at the same time kind of working on what the next thing might be or uses it one thing at a time and you're good to just kind of be shooting only one thing every kind of year and a half or two years or something. You know, gemstones is about 15 months between
看看我们能用它做什么。太棒了。你理想的工作频率是多少？你住在那里，有所有的朋友和同事。你们喜欢总是手里有正在拍摄的东西，同时又在构思下一个项目，还是说一次只做一件事，每一年半或两年拍一部就够了？你知道，《宝石人生》在写剧本、拍摄和后期制作之间大约需要15个月
like writing it and then shooting it and then and post and so that's taken I've been on that, you know, one one season right after the next but it was funny I moved here because I kind of was feeling like I was working too much when I was in Los Angeles. I didn't know how to like shut it down. My kids were starting to kind of like take notice of me being gone. And so I sort of like sold it to my wife that like moving to Charleston, we'd be able to chill. And I think we could like, busier here. Is your wife from, is your wife from the South?
所以这占用了我，你知道，一季接一季，但很有趣，我搬到这里是因为我当时觉得我在洛杉矶工作太多了。我不知道怎么停下来。我的孩子们开始注意到我不在家。所以我向我妻子推销说，搬到查尔斯顿，我们就能放松一下。我觉得我们在这里更忙了。你妻子是南方人吗？
She's not. She's from Los Angeles. And so she, she was, I really wanted to make sure she was okay with this because I, I kind of appreciate the, uh, the, uh, I don't know, I appreciate all the, the, the weird, strange things about the South and, and that, not everyone does. And, uh, so I didn't think I was wanting to make sure she was going to dig it, but she loves it here. And then her mom is an Angelino. She moved here just a few years ago, fallin' us down here too.
她不是。她来自洛杉矶。所以我，我真的很想确保她对此没问题，因为我，我有点欣赏，呃，呃，我不知道，我欣赏南方所有那些奇怪、奇特的东西，而且，并不是每个人都喜欢。所以我不认为我想确保她会喜欢它，但她很喜欢这里。然后她妈妈是洛杉矶人。她几年前也搬到这里，跟着我们过来了。
And it's been awesome. It's been a lot of fun. Now, the way that you're describing it, I love Charleston. And I actually really like this out too. And so I was like, I'm kinda jealous the way you're talking about it. And like, I know, fuck it up.
这太棒了。这很有趣。现在，你描述它的方式，我喜欢查尔斯顿。我其实也很喜欢南方。所以我有点嫉妒你谈论它的方式。而且，我知道，搞砸了。
Maybe we should, guys, should we just move Charleston and be like, I know. Everybody talks about it, but you guys did it. Let's talk to show on the road. Does your wife work with you at all? She does it not now. just moves. Carlson, me, everybody talks about it, but you guys did it. Let's talk to show in the road. Does your wife work with you at all? She does it, not now. She was a, she was a private chef for a while when I met her.
也许我们应该，伙计们，我们应该搬到查尔斯顿吗？我知道。每个人都在谈论它，但你们真的做到了。让我们把节目带上路吧。你妻子和你一起工作吗？她不，现在不了。只是搬家。查尔斯顿，我，每个人都在谈论它，但你们真的做到了。让我们把节目带上路吧。你妻子和你一起工作吗？她不，现在不了。她曾经，她曾经是一名私人厨师。
She was, she would like translate for deaf and blind students at UCLA. And that's what she was doing when I met her. And then she became a personal chef for a while. And yeah, now she's like, she's an artist too. She like makes bags and paints. And so she's been, she's an artist too. She like makes bags and paints and stuff. She's been so pretty busy down here. Do you find that your kids are looking at what you do
她曾经在加州大学洛杉矶分校为聋哑学生做翻译。这就是我遇见她时她在做的事。然后她做了一段时间私人厨师。是的，现在她，她也是个艺术家。她制作包包和绘画。所以她，她也是个艺术家。她制作包包和绘画之类的。她在这里一直很忙。你发现你的孩子们在看你做的事
as something that they might wanna do or they like our kids, they don't give it up. They're like, they don't give it up. My daughter kind of gives it up. My daughter is eight years old and she loves everything that we do. She sees it. She goes to school and you tubes me and like, we'll come home saying stuff.
作为他们可能想做的事情，还是他们像我们的孩子一样，他们不买账。他们不买账。我女儿有点买账。我女儿八岁，她喜欢我们做的一切。她看到了。她去学校，在YouTube上搜我，然后会回家说一些话。
Come on. She's like, she should not be saying anything. Oh really? And my son doesn't give it up at all. I mean, I think you would rather do anything, but what I'm doing probably. What's Declan into right now? Declan is into right now.
得了吧。她说，她不应该说任何话。哦，真的吗？我儿子一点也不买账。我是说，我觉得他宁愿做任何事，也不愿做我正在做的事。德克兰现在对什么感兴趣？德克兰现在对什么感兴趣？
What is he into? See a sports guy? Is he a sports guy? Is he a video game guy? He is. He's video games. He's kind of whatever like all his friends are playing in sports at the time. And you know, he has it all. Like the kind of the cool thing about where we live is the kids can actually just like go
他对什么感兴趣？是个体育迷吗？是个体育迷吗？是个电子游戏迷吗？他是。他是电子游戏迷。他就像他所有的朋友当时在玩什么运动一样。而且你知道，他什么都有。住在我们这里的好处是孩子们真的可以
outside and go jam. You know, like when we first, we've got a LA, my son was like asking me, like if I would teach him how to ride a bike, and I'm like, why? Yeah, you're never gonna take a bike ride off a moha on up here. Yeah. Yeah, so sidewalks, it's all hell.
出去玩。你知道，当我们刚离开洛杉矶时，我儿子问我，如果我能教他骑自行车，我说，为什么？是的，你永远不会在这里骑自行车。是的。是的，所以人行道，全是地狱。
Unless you want me to drive you to a parking lot and watch you drive around in circles and stuff. Yeah, dude, that's what I do. That's how I do. I had to put a bike in the back of my car. We live up here in Moha on to the drive three miles to a park to teach my kid how to ride. And now they can't use it because there's nowhere to ride.
除非你想让我开车送你去停车场，看着你绕圈骑。是的，伙计，这就是我做的。这就是我做的。我不得不把自行车放在车后。我们住在这里，开车三英里去公园教我孩子骑车。现在他们不能用了，因为没地方骑。
So he's into that. The outdoors is like, you know, I mean, it's kind of wild like the other day. So there's a knock in the door and there's like 10 kids on bikes like Declan here, you know, and they all love that. I love that. That's how they go. I got to get like a playstation or an Xbox or something for Maple because Willie, we came over to your house the other night and Maple went upstairs and Able and her played
所以他喜欢那个。户外活动就像，你知道，我是说，这有点狂野，就像那天。有人敲门，有10个孩子骑着自行车，就像德克兰在这里，你知道，他们都喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。他们就是那样。我得给梅普尔买个PlayStation或Xbox之类的，因为威利，那天晚上我们去你家，梅普尔上楼了，艾布尔和她玩了
video games for a couple hours. I went up there and watched a little bit. It's incredible. Like, I grew up on a Tari and in television and the graphics, the complexity, it's so bitching. I mean, I think it would be, I mean, I got to get it from me, let alone her. I got to an Xbox a few years ago. We played for a minute, but I, you know, that Xbox came from you. Yeah, man. Yeah. It's sitting in there. We played us, what was a super, some superhero thing for a little while,
几个小时电子游戏。我上楼看了一会儿。太不可思议了。我是说，我从小玩雅达利和Intellivision长大，图形、复杂性，太棒了。我是说，我觉得这会是，我是说，我得给自己买一个，更不用说她了。我几年前买了一个Xbox。我们玩了一会儿，但是，你知道，那个Xbox是你给的。是的，伙计。是的。它就在那儿。我们玩了，是什么，某种超级英雄游戏玩了一会儿，
and then that was it. But I'm talking about, they were playing Fortnite, and this is just like, what a world that is. I played with, I played with, like years and years and years ago, you called me, or you got me Call of Duty, or one of those games. Yeah, yeah, I played it, yeah, with the headset, and I played it for a minute, and I was like,
然后就那样了。但我说的是，他们在玩《堡垒之夜》，这简直是，那是一个什么样的世界。我玩过，我玩过，就像多年前，你打电话给我，或者你给我买了《使命召唤》或者那些游戏之一。是的，是的，我玩过，是的，戴着耳机，我玩了一会儿，我心想，
I couldn't get out the door without getting shot over and over again. Like, we got it, well, with the headset. And I played it for a minute. And I was like, I couldn't get out the door without getting shot over and over again. Like, we got it. Well, remember we talked about with Krizenski, God made us all play when it first came out in 2007. And Thoreau, who you did, your highness, we're off with him. And Travathunder, I was wondering,
我还没出门就被反复射击。就像，我们得到了，嗯，戴着耳机。我玩了一会儿。我心想，我还没出门就被反复射击。就像，我们得到了。嗯，记得我们和克拉辛斯基谈过吗，上帝让我们在2007年刚出来时都玩。还有索罗，你拍了《王子殿下》，我们和他一起。还有特拉瓦桑德，我在想，
did, I'm trying to remember if you were sleeves in your highness. No, probably not sleeves, I don't know. So, did you guys had a little call of No, probably not sleeves. I don't know. Right. So did you guys had a little call of duty lead going? But we had a legal ingestion was like, we used to, I remember years ago, Thoreau and I were out. It was a real great look.
你是不是《王子殿下》里的斯利夫斯。不，可能不是斯利夫斯，我不知道。所以，你们有一个小小的《使命召唤》联盟吗？不，可能不是斯利夫斯。我不知道。对。所以你们有一个小小的《使命召唤》联盟吗？但我们有一个合法的摄入量，就像，我们过去，我记得多年前，索罗和我出去。那是一个很棒的样子。
A bunch of 40-year-olds. We were out for dinner. We were out for dinner with our ladies. We were at the time, almost 40, and he'd go, and he and I are trying to wrap up dinner real early and we're like eating a stuff that we got the check because there were a bunch of dudes were all gonna be playing online and finally one of the ladies goes, are you fucking guys rushing us out of dinner so you can get home to play your fucking video game?
一群40岁的人。我们出去吃晚饭。我们和我们的女士们出去吃晚饭。当时，快40岁了，他说，他和我在努力早点结束晚餐，我们就像在吃东西，我们拿到了账单，因为有一群家伙都要在线玩游戏，最后其中一位女士说，你们这些混蛋是在催我们吃完晚饭，好让你们回家玩你们该死的电子游戏吗？
What? What? What? What's you? What's crowd dare you? After that I went back to my Super Mario brothers. Danny, listen, do you miss anything about LA that you so had readily available
什么？什么？什么？什么？你？什么？敢吗？在那之后我回到了我的《超级马里奥兄弟》。丹尼，听着，你怀念洛杉矶的什么吗，那些你曾经唾手可得的
that maybe anything at all? Yeah, I mean, I love living out in Los Angeles. I really did. I lived there for almost 20 years and so lots of friends and Mexican food and... Yeah. But it's been cool. It's been a nice change and it gets me up to New York more.
也许任何东西？是的，我是说，我喜欢住在洛杉矶。我真的喜欢。我在那里住了将近20年，所以有很多朋友和墨西哥食物和……是的。但这很酷。这是一个不错的改变，它让我更多地去纽约。
I go and finish a post on the show up in New York and oh, really? I love being up there. So so this slow. Not I've just never been. I just imagine because it's not a major city. Sean, you've never been in Charleston, South Carolina. No, it's going to blow your mind. I would love to go.
我去纽约完成节目的后期制作，哦，真的吗？我喜欢待在那里。所以，这么慢。不是，我只是从来没去过。我只是想象，因为它不是一个大城市。肖恩，你从来没去过南卡罗来纳州的查尔斯顿。不，这会让你大吃一惊的。我很想去。
It's going to let me take you. Come on. Let me show you my Charleston. But, but does it does these for I don't mean this to be insulting in any way to anybody. That is the slower. It's I imagine it's slower than a big city. Whoa. That's something you miss. It is slower and I think I was so tuned to Los Angeles that like when I went back to Los Angeles after living here for a few months, I really found myself like not able to keep up.
这会让我带你去。来吧。让我带你看看我的查尔斯顿。但是，但是这些，我不是想以任何方式侮辱任何人。那是更慢的。我想象它比大城市慢。哇。那是你怀念的东西吗？它确实更慢，我想我太适应洛杉矶了，以至于我在那里住了几个月后回到洛杉矶，我真的发现自己无法跟上节奏。
I was like, God, it's just so loud and crowded here and kind of like I was used to it. I, you know, everybody here is just super friendly which when we moved here, every for a week, people were coming by and just bringing baked goods to our house. And then one time we came home and they had just like laid it inside the house. Like they had opened up the front door and just like put the cup things.
我心想，天哪，这里太吵、太拥挤了，而且我有点习惯了。我，你知道，这里每个人都超级友好，当我们搬到这里时，每个人，有一周，人们过来给我们家送烘焙食品。然后有一次我们回家，他们直接把它放在屋里了。就像他们打开前门，把杯子之类的东西放进去。
You sure had blown off in Los Angeles. And you go, oh my God. I know. I do want to, I, that's something about that seems so peel. We know it's funny. Like Abel was telling me the other day, Abel's my 12 year old and he was telling me that he'd gone to a friend's house. I picked him up and I said, how was he?
你在洛杉矶肯定会被吹走。你会说，哦，天哪。我知道。我确实想，我，那是关于那件事看起来如此吸引人的地方。我们知道这很有趣。就像艾布尔那天告诉我的，艾布尔是我12岁的儿子，他告诉我他去了一个朋友家。我接他时，我说，他怎么样？
He's like, it was pretty good. We went to this other person's house. I picked him up and I said, how was he? He's like, it was pretty good. We went to this other person's house. We walked over, which is unusual, right? We like, we walked over from so-and-so's house back to Jonas's house. I was like, cool. And he goes, and we played, you know, Ding Dong ditch, whatever, you know, it's got so many different names, but you know, playing Ding Dong ditch and I went, hey man, no, you can't do that in Los Angeles.
他说，还不错。我们去了这个人的家。我接他时，我说，他怎么样？他说，还不错。我们去了这个人的家。我们走过去的，这很不寻常，对吧？我们就像，我们从某某家走回乔纳斯的家。我说，酷。他说，我们玩了，你知道，叮咚逃跑，不管怎样，你知道，它有很多不同的名字，但你知道，玩叮咚逃跑，我说，嘿伙计，不，你在洛杉矶不能那样做。
It's true. Because people get fucking, yeah, I was like, no, no, no, no. Yeah. It's such a bummer. Yeah, it's such a bummer that you can't do that unless Angeles. It's true because people get fucking, yeah, I was like, no, no, no. Yeah, it's such a bummer. Yeah, it's such a bummer that you can't go. And Charleston, you can still egg houses probably. You definitely can still egg houses, yeah. Like this, this sound nice, art like our, we have this older couple that lives next door to us.
这是真的。因为人们会该死的，是的，我说，不，不，不，不。是的。这太扫兴了。是的，你在洛杉矶不能那样做真是太扫兴了。这是真的，因为人们会该死的，是的，我说，不，不，不。是的。这太扫兴了。是的，你不能去真是太扫兴了。在查尔斯顿，你可能还能往房子上扔鸡蛋。你绝对还能往房子上扔鸡蛋，是的。就像这个，这个听起来不错，像我们的，我们有这对老夫妇住在我们隔壁。
And they're so awesome. They're so friendly, so nice. And last summer, there was like a hurricane that came through here. And we were shooting gemstones. It was one of those things where we had a decide, like, are we gonna shut down production? Are we gonna let people go home?
他们太棒了。他们太友好，太好了。去年夏天，这里有一场飓风经过。我们当时在拍《宝石人生》。那是我们需要决定的事情之一，比如，我们要停产吗？我们要让人们回家吗？
Like, is this gonna come? Is it gonna hit us? And we ended up like shutting down production. People went home, but we shut it down. Like the day it was arriving. And so my wife and one of our friends like scurried around the house, like trying to like secure the stuff outside from blowing around.
比如，这会来吗？它会击中我们吗？我们最终决定停产。人们回家了，但我们在它到达的那天停产了。所以我妻子和我们的一个朋友在房子周围匆忙跑，试图把外面的东西固定住，防止被吹走。
And so they did all that and I come home. We just like decide we're going to wait the hurricane out. We're just going to drink wine and chill and like watch it. And so that's what we do. And it's a blast. We're having a great time watching. If you can get inside the actual eye. That's the same. We're hearing each other to run outside. But people like, right, as the worst part of the storm passed, our next door neighbor like texts my wife. And she's like, oh, this is horrible. And my wife was like, oh, it's fine.
所以他们做了所有这些，我回家了。我们只是决定我们要等飓风过去。我们只是要喝点酒，放松一下，看着它。所以这就是我们做的。这太棒了。我们看着它玩得很开心。如果你能进入真正的风眼。那是一样的。我们听到对方跑出去。但人们就像，就在风暴最糟糕的部分过去时，我们的邻居给我妻子发短信。她说，哦，这太可怕了。我妻子说，哦，没关系。
Just drink some wine. It's great. It's like, it's almost done. And she's like, no, this is horrible. And she sends a picture of this 25 pound dumbbell from our gym underneath the house and it had flown through their second story window and was like sitting in their dining room. She's bust through.
喝点酒就好了。太棒了。就像，快结束了。她说，不，这太可怕了。她发了一张照片，是我们健身房里的25磅哑铃，它飞过了他们二楼的窗户，就像坐在他们的餐厅里。她撞破了。
And I'm like, what the fuck, how would that have happened? How would a weight have gotten up there? And so I go downstairs where the gym is, the garage door shut, everything's in there. I'm like, what the fuck, how did this get up there? And then I look out in the backyard, I'm like, the trampoline. Where's the trampoline? And so I go up in my wife and her friend had put the weights on the trampoline to wait now. And then, I got a win, took it and it fucking sailed.
我心想，这他妈是怎么回事？重量是怎么飞到那儿去的？所以我下楼去健身房，车库门关着，所有东西都在里面。我心想，这他妈是怎么飞到那儿去的？然后我看向后院，我心想，蹦床。蹦床在哪儿？所以我上去，我妻子和她的朋友把重量放在蹦床上压住。然后，我，风把它带走了，它他妈的航行了。
It's like, it flew up in the air and flew into the front yard and threw the dumbbell right through their window. I thought for sure, I thought it was so mortified. I had no idea what we should do. Like, when we go over now, do we let them come to our house and they, they never were bothered by it. They were so friendly. Oh, it's not your fault. They actually baked you a fresh baked. They were like, incredible. I'm like, this would have been out. This could have been worse. This could have been a waste. Sean, Sean, didn't you tell me about a club you went to once where everything that wasn't tied down got blown?
它就像，它飞到空中，飞进前院，把哑铃直接扔进了他们的窗户。我以为肯定，我以为这太丢人了。我不知道我们该做什么。比如，我们现在过去时，我们让他们来我们家，他们从来没被困扰过。他们太友好了。哦，这不是你的错。他们实际上给你烤了一个新鲜的。他们就像，不可思议。我心想，这本来会是。这本来会更糟。这本来会是浪费。肖恩，肖恩，你没告诉过我你曾经去过的一个俱乐部，那里所有没绑住的东西都被吹走了吗？
I think it was called dumbbells too, wasn't it? Yeah, I just, after a while they let me in. I didn't have to see the bounce or anything. That's so fucking crazy though. What an awesome story. Honestly, Sean, I, because I know Sean, every time Sean goes to a different, and Jay's like this too, actually, I think everybody is, but every time he go to a different place, Sean's, I was like, I want to move you.
我想它也叫哑铃，不是吗？是的，我只是，过了一会儿他们让我进去了。我不需要看保镖什么的。这太他妈疯狂了。多么棒的故事。老实说，肖恩，我，因为我认识肖恩，每次肖恩去一个不同的地方，杰伊也是这样，其实，我想每个人都是，但每次他去一个不同的地方，肖恩的，我心想，我想搬到你那儿。
So I was looking at real estate. Yeah, I do. I'm meeting with Sean. I'm really looking at links. I know. It's amazing. And, and so I think that if Sean were to come, Sean, if you were to go down to South Carolina, you would be like, sorry man,
所以我一直在看房地产。是的，我一直在看。我和肖恩见面。我真的在看链接。我知道。这太神奇了。而且，所以我认为如果肖恩要来，肖恩，如果你要去南卡罗来纳州，你会说，抱歉伙计，
we're moving to South Carolina. I know I have a couple of friends that live there, and I know I just never been there. And now, a word from our sponsor. Thanks to GoodRx for supporting the show. Summer is in full swing, and we're all looking for ways to save money for road trips, stay-cations, or I don't know know summer camp for the kids. You may not expect to find a
我们要搬到南卡罗来纳州了。我知道我有几个朋友住在那里，而且我知道我从来没去过那里。现在，来自我们赞助商的一句话。感谢GoodRx支持本节目。夏天正如火如荼，我们都在寻找省钱的方法，为了公路旅行、宅度假，或者我不知道，孩子们的夏令营。你可能没想到会在药房柜台找到
deal at the pharmacy counter but hey with goodRx you can instantly save up to 80% on your prescription medications. Using goodRx is easy and totally free. All you need to do is search for your prescription on the goodRx website or app and show your discount at the pharmacy. With goodRx you can find prescription savings at the pharmacies right in your neighborhood including CVS, Walgreens, RIDade, Vans, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more. And remember good Rx works whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance goodRx could possibly beat your copay price. So when you're filling prescriptions a summer, don't forget to check goodRx before you get to the pharmacy.
优惠，但嘿，有了GoodRx，你可以立即在处方药上节省高达80%。使用GoodRx既简单又完全免费。你所要做的就是在GoodRx网站或应用程序上搜索你的处方，并在药房出示你的折扣。有了GoodRx，你可以在你附近的药房找到处方药优惠，包括CVS、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、沃尔玛、山姆会员店等等。记住，无论你是否有保险，GoodRx都有效。即使你有保险，GoodRx也可能比你的共付额价格更便宜。所以当你在这个夏天配药时，别忘了在去药房之前查看GoodRx。
I have a medication that I have to take every day, a very specific medication, and GoodRx helped me save when I went to the counter at my pharmacy. And it was awesome. I was like, oh my god, I saved all this money. So why am I at the pharmacy? I can just grab a pack of all these candy bars. That's what I did, by the way.
我有一种必须每天服用的药物，一种非常特殊的药物，当我走到药房柜台时，GoodRx帮我省了钱。这太棒了。我心想，哦，天哪，我省了这么多钱。所以我为什么在药房？我可以买一包这些糖果棒。顺便说一句，我就是这么做的。
For simple smart savings on your prescriptions, check GoodRx, go to goodrx.com slash smartless. That's goodrx.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. It's a lot of golf down there, Danny. Do you play golf at all? I've played. I'm not any good, but I definitely,
想要在处方药上获得简单、明智的节省，请查看GoodRx，访问goodrx.com/smartless。那是goodrx.com/smartless。现在回到节目。那里有很多高尔夫，丹尼。你打高尔夫吗？我打过。我打得不好，但我绝对，
you have to go out, you have to get, I mean, everyone golfs down here. There's some pretty cool spots, too. But what about the heat? Good Lord. I think I've got the ocean to jump in. Yeah, and you know, it's only really bad in the summertime. The rest of the year, it's pretty mild.
你必须出去，你必须去，我是说，每个人都在这里打高尔夫。也有一些很酷的地方。但热量呢？天哪。我想我有海洋可以跳进去。是的，而且你知道，它只在夏天真的很糟糕。一年中的其余时间，它相当温和。
It's great, but I feel like even if it's humid or if it's not humid, if it's above like 85, regardless, my ass is inside anyway. I'm not going to be in that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, I want to, I really is inside anyway. I'm not gonna be, I'm just saying that. Well, I really wanna go. Tell us about what that moment was when, so Will Farrell and Adam McKay, they see FootFist way, they say, yes, please, we wanna work it.
这很棒，但我觉得即使潮湿或者不潮湿，如果气温超过85度，无论如何，我的屁股反正都在里面。我不会在那儿的。是的，是的，是的。好吧，我想要，我真的反正都在里面。我不会在那儿的，我只是说说而已。好吧，我真的很想去。告诉我们当威尔·法瑞尔和亚当·麦凯看到《脚拳道》时，他们说，是的，请，我们想合作。
What was that start of that collaboration or that relationship with those guys like and them sort of nurturing you and validating you? And was that, did you know at the time that, okay, this is a nice greased path into what we really want to do? Or did you think it was just kind of like a one time thing? We had no clue.
那次合作或那种关系对你们来说是什么样的，他们培养你并认可你？那是，你当时知道，好吧，这是一个通往我们真正想做的事情的很好的润滑路径吗？还是你认为这只是一次性的事情？我们毫无头绪。
I mean, honestly, we were so, it was funny. Like I went to film school and I had been kind of trying to do this. I wasn't trying to be an actor. I went to film school for writing and directing. And you know, but then when the moment came, it was sort of like we were just kind of both of us were shocked. I mean, it was like we went from like, you know, just doing our day jobs to suddenly like meeting our heroes and meeting people that were doing it for
我是说，老实说，我们太，这很有趣。就像我上了电影学校，我一直在尝试做这个。我不是想成为一名演员。我上电影学校是为了写作和导演。而且你知道，但当那一刻到来时，就像我们俩都震惊了。我是说，就像我们从，你知道，只是做我们的日常工作，突然就像见到我们的英雄，见到那些以此为生的人。
living. And it was an incredible like time period. And you know, Adam and Will set us down and asked us what we wanted to do next. And that's when we pitched them Eastbound and down. And they were kind of confused that we wanted to make a TV show. They're like, well, most people try to make TV shows to get movies. You know, like you already have the movie. You don't need to do the TV show. And you were like, yeah, I don't know. There's something about this.
那是一段不可思议的时期。而且你知道，亚当和威尔让我们坐下来，问我们接下来想做什么。那就是我们向他们推销《体育老师笑传》的时候。他们有点困惑我们想拍一部电视剧。他们说，好吧，大多数人尝试拍电视剧是为了拍电影。你知道，就像你已经有了电影。你不需要拍电视剧。而你们说，是的，我不知道。这东西有点什么。
We just, we feel like it would work better as a TV show. And yeah, I feel like that show is good. That being attached is the only reason I think why the show stayed alive. You know, we sold that show to a different regime at HBO. And then, you know, I think when the new people showed up, I think they were kind of like, what did we buy? Like, what is this? Like, I remember seeing, we are, we're like, had a week left to shoot and we got these
我们只是，我们觉得它作为电视剧会更好。是的，我觉得那部剧很好。被附带是唯一的原因，我想为什么这部剧能活下来。你知道，我们把那部剧卖给了HBO的一个不同政权。然后，你知道，我想当新的人出现时，我想他们有点像，我们买了什么？比如，这是什么？比如，我记得看到，我们就像，还有一周就要拍完了，我们接到了这些
panic calls. I think it was the first time that anyone had watched what we were doing down in North Carolina. And they were asking like, can you give Kenny Powers like a dog? Can he have a kid that he helps? Like, anything that we can do in the last week here to make this guy more likeable. What was, where did the, are you a baseball fan? Where did the, where did the, the, the world come from?
恐慌电话。我想这是第一次有人看了我们在北卡罗来纳州做的事情。他们问，你能给肯尼·鲍尔斯一只狗吗？他能有一个他帮助的孩子吗？比如，我们在最后一周能做的任何事情，让这个家伙更讨人喜欢。什么是，哪里来的，你是棒球迷吗？哪里来的，哪里来的，哪里来的，世界？
You know, that's like I, I wasn't a baseball fan. I mean, I am now, You know, that's like, I wasn't a bass player. I mean, I am now, but that's the thing. When I was writing it, I never even thought about that I would need to know how to throw or pitch right. Until we got down to shoot the pilot, and they like, do we need to get a specialist or something? I'm like, yeah, sure. So we got this guy from the local college,
你知道，那就像我，我不是棒球迷。我是说，我现在是，你知道，那就像我，我不是贝斯手。我是说，我现在是，但这就是重点。当我写它的时候，我甚至没想过我需要知道怎么投球。直到我们去拍试播集，他们就像，我们需要找个专家什么的吗？我说，是的，当然。所以我们从当地大学找了这个人，
and he's like, let me see what you have. And I threw a ball. He's like, oh, Jesus. So we got this guy from the local college. And he's like, let me see what you have. And I threw a ball. He's like, oh, Jesus, good thing this is a comedy. It's like, you know, so I was like constantly being like, well, he's a failed pitcher, right? Yeah, there's a reason he's not doing well. So every time I throw the ball, it always like punches in right past me.
他说，让我看看你有什么。我扔了一个球。他说，哦，天哪。所以我们从当地大学找了这个人。他说，让我看看你有什么。我扔了一个球。他说，哦，天哪，幸好这是喜剧。就像，你知道，所以我一直在说，好吧，他是个失败的投手，对吧？是的，他表现不好是有原因的。所以每次我扔球，它总是像在我身后打孔。
You never were able to see my full form. Oh my God. I have a question about like for all three of you guys. Go for Sean. Yeah, sure. Thank you. I give this question about like for all three of you guys. Go for Sean. Sure, thank you. Again, this is a great venue for your questions. When you, Danny, when you, and by the way, I want to know, Jason, with you directing and writing Will, I know you've all written and starred in something or directed and starred
你从来没能看到我的完整形式。哦，天哪。我有一个关于你们三个人的问题。去吧，肖恩。是的，当然。谢谢。我有一个关于你们三个人的问题。去吧，肖恩。当然，谢谢。再一次，这是你们提问的好地方。当你，丹尼，当你，顺便说一句，我想知道，杰森，你导演和写作威尔，我知道你们都写过并主演过什么，或者导演并主演过什么
in something. Is it a lot like the older you get? Are you feeling like, you know, it's really great to wear a lot of hats, but maybe just the one hat now is fine. Like, where you prefer just to show up and know your lines as an actor and then go home. Or do you still enjoy doing it all? I like that every once in a while,
什么。是不是越老越像？你觉得，你知道，戴很多帽子真的很棒，但也许现在只戴一顶帽子也很好。比如，你更喜欢只是作为演员出现，知道你的台词，然后回家。还是你仍然喜欢做这一切？我喜欢偶尔，
just to show up and wait for them to knock on the trailer and say time to come out and talk, and then you do that for about 10 minutes and then you go back. Yeah, because it just seems like an overwhelming amount of... I find it the reverse, the older I get, the more I just wanna do this stuff that I create. Yeah.
只是露个面，等着他们敲房车的门说该出来谈谈了，然后你做个10分钟，再回去。是啊，因为这看起来简直让人不知所措……我反而觉得，我年纪越大，就越想做这些我自己创作的东西。是啊。
Yeah. And work hard, hard, hard, yeah. Yeah, but I did work hard, but also like then you get to control and Danny's been doing it for a long time. I know, that's why I was asking like Danny also, like, then you get to control, and Danny's been doing it for a long time. I know, that's why I was asking, like, Danny, too. Like, don't you, I'm just thinking about the Halloween things or anything,
是啊。而且要努力、努力、再努力，是啊。是啊，我确实很努力，但同时你也能掌控局面，丹尼已经做这行很久了。我知道，所以我才问，丹尼也是，你也能掌控局面，丹尼已经做这行很久了。我知道，所以我才问，丹尼也是。比如，你难道不……我只是在想万圣节的事情或者其他什么，
where you write, but then you go run off an act and now this show that you're in right now, you're doing both, it just seems like a lot. It is a lot, you know, show running is definitely difficult, I mean, that kind of process of having to deal with the scripts at the same time you're dealing with production and it's a ton. And then go have to, and then act.
你既要写剧本，又要跑去演戏，现在你参与的这部剧，你两样都在做，这看起来工作量很大。确实很大，你知道，担任剧集运作人绝对很困难，我是说，那种既要处理剧本，又要处理制作的过程，工作量太大了。然后还得去演戏。
And then you have to know your lines. Yeah, have your energy up for it. I just like the collaboration of filmmaking a lot. Like I love working with the guys that I direct with. So sometimes I just get lonely if it's just me directing. It's like, it's just on the only one here. And where I like working with the other guys, I like what we come up with together.
而且你还得背台词。是啊，还得保持充沛的精力。我只是非常喜欢电影制作中的协作。我喜欢和我一起执导的伙伴们合作。所以有时候如果只是我一个人执导，我会感到孤独。就像是，这里只有我一个人。而我喜欢和其他人一起工作，我喜欢我们共同想出的点子。
I think there's something fun about that. Danny, are you watching somebody or something right now that's keeping you kind of motivated and thinking forward? And like, I don't know, I was thinking for, we were talking about Halloween and combining comedy and filmmaking and all this stuff. Like Jordan Peel's a really exciting guy nowadays. It gets me really, really excited in that world.
我觉得这很有趣。丹尼，你现在有没有在看什么人或什么东西，能让你保持动力并向前看？我不知道，我在想，我们刚才在谈论万圣节，谈论将喜剧和电影制作结合起来等等。比如乔丹·皮尔现在就是一个非常令人兴奋的人。他在那个领域让我感到非常非常兴奋。
Are you watching him or somebody like that that's floating your boat? Yeah, I definitely like him a lot. You know, like, weirdly, when it comes to TV stuff, I find myself just watching like reality TV. Like, my brain just doesn't want to commit to anything. So, like I'm all about the Vanderpumps right now. That should on fire. Right. Everybody.
你在看他或者像他那样的人吗？是啊，我确实很喜欢他。你知道，奇怪的是，说到电视节目，我发现自己只会看真人秀。我的大脑不想投入到任何需要动脑的事情上。所以，我现在沉迷于《范德普泵》（Vanderpump Rules）。那节目简直火爆。没错。每个人都在看。
It is a wipe out. Is it? It's so good. Do you watch it, Jay? Yeah, I've seen it. It's just I just I love all that. And it's also just the way they make those shows now, the whole reality world. It's really well done, you know, like they've figured it out.
那简直是一场灾难。是吗？太好看了。你看吗，杰伊？看过。我就是喜欢这些。而且现在制作这些节目的方式，整个真人秀世界，做得非常好，你知道，他们已经摸透了门道。
There's a format there and they're starting to play with the form a little bit too. And it's, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, we know Andy, we talked about Andy Cohen. I know Andy a little bit, and I saw a few clips recently. I guess some shit went down on Vanderpump recently that blew everybody's mind. There's like a fair, and a, oh yeah, there's a whole thing. And people don't like this person. Here's the thing, they talk about them like their characters. And so they have them on these follow-up shows
他们有一套模式，而且也开始在形式上做一些创新。而且，我们认识安迪，我们谈过安迪·科恩。我稍微认识安迪一点，最近看了几个片段。我想最近《范德普泵》里发生了一些惊天动地的事情。好像有个外遇，还有……哦对，有一大堆事。人们不喜欢这个人。问题是，他们谈论这些人就像谈论角色一样。所以他们会让他们上后续的节目，
and they're like, well, I think at that moment that so and so did this, I think that she's really coming to terms with them like, wait, this is not, you're talking about it. They're the real people. And she's sitting next to you. And she's sitting next to you. And you're talking like she's really making decisions that I don't think that she understands.
然后他们会说，嗯，我觉得在那一刻某某做了这个，我觉得她真的开始接受了，等等，这不是……你在谈论她。他们是真实的人。而且她就坐在你旁边。她就坐在你旁边。而你说话的样子，就像她真的在做一些我并不认为她能理解的决定。
And you're like, wait, what the fuck are we talking about, man? Yeah, it's strange. What is happening? It's so strange. It's so hard. They must fight the instinct or maybe they're asked to cause trouble, but you kind of fight the instinct to cause trouble to make for good drama probably. So I wonder how much of it is them trying to really contribute. That's what it's got to
你会想，等等，我们到底在谈论什么鬼东西？是啊，这很奇怪。到底发生了什么？太奇怪了。太难了。他们一定是在对抗本能，或者也许是有人要求他们制造麻烦，但你可能得对抗那种为了制造好戏而惹事的本能。所以我很好奇他们有多少是真心想参与其中。那一定就是
be. I mean, even the fact that like so many of these reality shows are on ensembles, you know, and it seems like everyone's fighting for their, you know, for their notoriety or for how they leave their mark become the most exciting Train for their water cooler moment. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's a true Vanderpump. I gotta watch it now. This season has been phenomenal It's how many so long as about you know, I stopped watching it for a while And then I heard the news about the affair that happened and I was I was like, I need to tune back in and see what these Vanderpump's been up to. And, uh, guys, Vanderpump, their name, no, it's Lisa Vanderpump is the lady who owns the restaurant. They all work out, but I like just saying it plural. I just think it sounds fun. Vanderpump 's, but wait, wait, that's what they'll ask you. That's somebody's last name on the show.
原因所在。我是说，甚至很多真人秀都是群像剧，你知道，每个人似乎都在为自己的名声，或者为如何留下印记，成为最令人兴奋的谈资而战。是啊。是啊。那是真正的《范德普泵》。我现在得去看了。这一季太精彩了。我停看了一段时间。然后我听说了那件外遇的事，我就想，我得重新看，看看这些范德普们在搞什么。而且，伙计们，范德普是他们的名字吗？不，丽莎·范德普是拥有那家餐厅的女士。他们都在那工作，但我喜欢用复数称呼。我觉得听起来很有趣。范德普们，等等，等等，他们会问你的。那是节目里某人的姓氏。
Yeah. And wait, and all these people work at her restaurant? That's right, yep. I still watch the Jersey Shore. You still watch the Jersey Shore, huh? I still watch it. But just for the big, burly dudes. Yeah. All right, so now you're power down for the summer, where are you and your little band of criminals
是啊。等等，这些人都在她的餐厅工作？没错，是的。我还在看《泽西海岸》。你还在看《泽西海岸》啊？我还在看。不过只是为了看那些大块头。是啊。好吧，现在你夏天要休息了，你和你那帮罪犯小团伙
going for the summer? Are you gonna take a big vacation? I think I am. My kids have never of criminals going for the summer. You're going to take a big vacation. I think I am. My kids have never really been outside of the country. So I think we've locked, we're going to do a straight up big European vacation. Yeah, that's good. We're going to Griswold,
夏天要去哪儿？你们要度个大假吗？我想是的。我的孩子们从来没……罪犯小团伙夏天要去哪儿。你要度个大假吗？我想是的。我的孩子们从来没真正出过国。所以我想我们已经锁定了，我们要去度一个彻彻底底的欧洲大假。是啊，那很好。我们要去像《疯狂假期》里的格里斯沃尔德一家那样，
and we're going to France to Italy, we're going to go to Germany. It's going to be awesome. So this is going to be one week, two weeks, three weeks? It's going to be seven weeks. Come on. Everybody's going to pick one little suitcase. That's our deal. And we're meeting different people on the way. Walton Goggins, a him or a love Walton. We've rented a fortress in Sicily for a week. So I'll see his family at one point. Now are you going to drive like the Griswolds? Are you going to take trains or is it going
我们要去法国、意大利，还要去德国。那一定会很棒。所以这次是去一周、两周，还是三周？是七周。得了吧。每个人只能带一个小行李箱。这是我们的约定。我们会在路上见不同的人。沃尔顿·戈金斯，我爱沃尔顿。我们在西西里岛租了一座堡垒住一周。所以我到时候会见到他的家人。那你打算像格里斯沃尔德一家那样开车吗？还是坐火车，或者
to be a combination of all? It's a combo of both. I'm gonna try to run a car as much as I can. I just wanna get the full experience, but we'll train it up a little bit too. Seven. I tell you what, driving in Italy is the best because you think like it's, people are like, no, that must be insane. I'm like, no, it's the best because there's a method
两者结合？两者结合。我会尽量多租车。我只是想获得完整的体验，但我们也会坐坐火车。七周。我告诉你，在意大利开车是最棒的，因为你觉得……人们会说，不，那一定很疯狂。我说，不，那是最好的，因为疯狂之中自有章法，
to the madness of it and it makes sense. It's not like here where nobody drives with the, nobody uses a turn signal and all that shit. Everybody's the worst. Over there, it's everything happening. You drive in Germany so you can go without any, any speed limit on the out of the whole thing, right? That's where that's the climax of the vacation. Sure it is. Right. It's okay to help you build because you're at the end. Yeah. She's it. But seven weeks all together, I mean, have you guys done that? Wait, we've never done it before. Yeah. She's it. But seven weeks all together, I mean, have you guys done that?
而且很有道理。不像这里，没人开车打转向灯，诸如此类。每个人都是最差劲的。在那边，一切都在发生。你在德国开车，所以你可以在全程没有任何限速的情况下行驶，对吧？那是假期的最高潮。当然是。没错。这有助于你建立期待，因为那是最后。是啊。就是这样。但是总共七周，我是说，你们以前这样做过吗？等等，我们以前从没这样做过。
Wait, we've never done it before. Yeah, we've never done it up. Yeah, I'm looking forward. I felt like now was the time. My son is like starting to get a lot of friends outside of his family circle. And I feel like it will be very hard, I think, in a year to convince him to like hang with his fam for the whole summer. I think now it's now. When you go on trips, guys, like, do you think about like, I think about like, where's the nearest hospital or a doctor or something should happen? Or you know what I mean?
等等，我们以前从没这样做过。是啊，我们从没这样做过。是啊，我很期待。我觉得现在是时候了。我儿子开始在家庭圈子之外结交很多朋友了。我觉得一年后，我可能很难说服他整个夏天都和家人待在一起。我觉得就是现在。你们去旅行的时候，伙计们，比如，你们会想，最近的医院或医生在哪里，以防万一吗？或者你知道我的意思吗？
Like, also I bat, like your, what is it called? What does it call the dopamine? No, the bag, the toiletry bag. Well, what is it called? Dog kit, dog kit. That your dog kit should have like all of the like, American, you know, Tylenol and like all the your dog kit should have like all of the like American, you know, Tylenol and like all the stuff that you should have ready.
比如，还有你的，那个叫什么？叫多巴胺？不，那个包，洗漱包。好吧，那叫什么？洗漱包，洗漱包。你的洗漱包里应该装满所有像美国的那种，你知道，泰诺之类的，还有所有你应该准备好的东西。
Okay. So you're real blast to you real blast to hang out with you know, that you are. You're real. You get injured a lot. No one in my family's allowed to get headaches while we're gone. Danny are all the are the family's passports up to date. Have you looked at that? Everybody's up to date.
好吧。和你待在一起真是太让人兴奋了，你知道的。你真是。你很容易受伤。我们家没人被允许在旅行时头疼。丹尼，家人的护照都还在有效期内吗？你看过吗？所有人的都在有效期内。
Yeah. That's a common like good. Yeah. Yeah. Everyone's excited for nothing. Yep. Nope. They're all up to date. I love. I'm so jealous. Why don't we all just move to South Carolina for real? Yeah.
是啊。那很好。是啊。是啊。每个人都兴奋得不得了。没错。不。它们都在有效期内。我爱。我太嫉妒了。为什么我们不干脆搬到南卡罗来纳州去呢？是啊。
Come to Charleston. Yeah. That's the first time. Let's go to Charleston. It's really nice down there. Oh my God. I can't wait to go. I'm not kidding. I want to go. I'm just jealous. Let me ask you Danny. Do you I know you say you love LA and there's a lot of great things about LA and I'm nice down there. Oh my God. I can't wait to go. I'm not kidding. I want to go. I'm just jealous.
来查尔斯顿吧。是啊。那是第一次。我们去查尔斯顿吧。那里真的很不错。天哪。我迫不及待想去了。我没开玩笑。我想去。我只是嫉妒。让我问你，丹尼。你……我知道你说你爱洛杉矶，洛杉矶有很多很棒的地方，那里真的很不错。天哪。我迫不及待想去了。我没开玩笑。我想去。我只是嫉妒。
Let me ask you, Dandard, I know you love LA, and there's a lot of great things about LA and New York. But do you kind of relish like being out of the grind a little bit that you get to have this kind of experience that is not just always folk? I know you work a lot, but here sometimes work in social life and all that can just become one because it's such a company town.
让我问你，丹尼，我知道你爱洛杉矶，洛杉矶和纽约有很多很棒的地方。但你是否有点享受那种远离忙碌的感觉，能有这种不总是……我知道你工作很忙，但在这里，工作和社交生活有时会合二为一，因为这是一个典型的公司城市。
Yeah. You kind of relish that that you don't, all your touch points aren't about, like Bateman, every single thing touch point in his life is about show business. Yeah, yeah. My underwear is just a trade paper. It's folded up nice.
是啊。你是否有点享受那种感觉，你的所有接触点都不是关于……比如贝特曼，他生活中的每一个接触点都是关于演艺圈的。是啊，是啊。我的内裤都是行业报纸做的。折叠得很整齐。
Everything is. He can't, everything is within the context the framework of show business. He has no real world experience. No, no. I, you know, I do, I do like that. I like getting away from it. I mean, you know what it's kind of cool about it
一切都是。他不能……一切都在演艺圈的框架内。他没有任何现实世界的经验。不，不。我，你知道，我确实喜欢那样。我喜欢远离它。我是说，你知道这有什么酷的吗？
is that I felt like when I was in LA, you see billboards everywhere. You're constantly thinking about work. You know, it's just, it's hard to get away from it. And here it's kind of cool because you don't see any of that. There's no billboards for any movies or TV shows are coming out. And then you kind of, it kind of puts it in perspective
就是我觉得在洛杉矶时，你到处都能看到广告牌。你一直在想工作。你知道，很难远离它。而在这里，这很酷，因为你看不到任何那些东西。没有任何电影或电视节目的广告牌。然后你就会，它会让你对
what you're doing, you know. They're like, this is just seasoning for people. It's not what the whole thing doesn't revolve around this. And when you entertain people, that's it. That's all you're just giving. Yeah. Well, you know, you can hear this. Yeah, no, that's it. That's all you're you're just Yeah, well, you know, Baby, can you hear this? Yeah, no, but you can hear it's not important, man. Right.
你所做的事情有一个客观的认识。他们会说，这只是人们的调味品。它不是……整个事情并不围绕这个转。当你娱乐人们时，就是这样。这就是你所给予的全部。是啊。好吧，你知道，你能听到这个。是啊，不，就是这样。这就是你所给予的全部。是啊，好吧，你知道，宝贝，你能听到这个吗？是啊，不，但你能听到，这并不重要，伙计。没错。
What about when you when you walk into a market, though, do people there do they just they go, oh my god, what what are you what are you doing here? This is a guy on movies and television. You know, people have been pretty cool. I think because I don't know. I think people know that I'm here. And so then they're sort of they're nice. I mean, you got to watch, you know, I don't go to bars or anything late at night when everybody's like, you know, admissions are down or any of that stuff. But yeah, I kind of, I mean, it's fun like going to like my kids just go to public school here. So I mean, like I love going to these like PTA meetings and these things just sitting in the back. I love it. I think it's I will say Danny reminds me of you've got because of a lot of the characters
当你走进市场时，人们会说，哦天哪，你在这里做什么？这是电影和电视里的人。你知道，人们一直都很酷。我想是因为我不知道。我想人们知道我住在这里。所以他们都很友善。我是说，你得小心，你知道，我不会在深夜去酒吧，当每个人都……你知道，神志不清的时候。但，是啊，我有点……我是说，这很有趣，比如去……我的孩子们在这里上公立学校。所以，我是说，我喜欢去参加这些家长会，坐在后面。我喜欢。我想我会说，丹尼让我想起了你，因为你扮演的很多角色
you've played it you mentioned and we all know that when you run into people after they've had a few cocktails that's when people feel like you're definitely taking a photo with me and you're like, Hey man, I'm eating dinner. I was like, Oh, care. You're taking a photo right now, but you're one you play a lot of these characters that dudes probably come up to you a lot super aggressively when they've had a few. Oh, 100%. Fuck yeah, can he power it?
你提到了，我们都知道，当你遇到那些喝了几杯鸡尾酒的人时，那是人们觉得你一定要跟我合影的时候，而你会说，嘿伙计，我正在吃晚饭。我当时想，哦，小心。你现在正在拍照，但你扮演了很多这样的角色，当那些家伙喝了几杯后，可能会非常咄咄逼人地走过来。哦，百分之百。去他妈的，他能应付吗？
Like I, I'm, you know, when you hang out with Farrell, he gets out a lot because everybody's like, he's like America's fucking best friend. So we're like, fuck yeah. Yeah, here comes Johnny. Can you tell me, can you're like, all right, man? It's always somebody like you can smell the booze and they're breath, they're putting their sweaty arm around you and they're on their phone trying to show you how they dressed up like you for Halloween. That's always that. That's always what it is.
就像我，你知道，当你和法瑞尔待在一起时，他经常出去，因为每个人都觉得，他就像是美国最好的朋友。所以我们想，去他妈的。是啊，强尼来了。你能告诉我，你能……你就像是，好吧，伙计？总是有人，你能闻到他们呼吸里的酒味，他们把汗津津的手臂搭在你身上，拿着手机想给你看他们万圣节是怎么打扮成你的。总是那样。总是这样。
That's hysterical. Yeah. Yeah. The dinner at 530. That's the key. That is the key. That's the key. That's the best. Danny, we appreciate your time. Thank you for sharing an hour with us, my friend. Wait, tell us again when gemstones is coming out. Gemstones, June 18th on June 18th. And then we're going to need the address of your place there in Charleston while you're gone for seven weeks.
太搞笑了。是啊。是啊。下午5点半吃晚饭。那是关键。那才是关键。那是关键。那是最好的。丹尼，我们感谢你的时间。谢谢你和我们分享了一个小时，我的朋友。等等，再告诉我们一次《宝石世家》什么时候播出。宝石世家，6月18日。6月18日。然后我们需要你在查尔斯顿的住址，当你离开七周的时候。
So we can just kind of try it out and stay in your house there. I think you should. So that's a great time to kind of test drive Charleston. I might do some exercise in your backyard on the trampoline with the weights. There you go. The trampoline is gone. All right. Danny, thank you, my friend.
这样我们就可以试住一下你的房子。我觉得你应该。所以这是一个试驾查尔斯顿的好时机。我可能会在你的后院蹦床上用哑铃做些运动。这就对了。蹦床已经没了。好吧。丹尼，谢谢你，我的朋友。
Have a great trip this summer. Everybody watch Gemstones and please come back and talk to us anytime you want. Thanks, Danny. Thank you so much. Thanks for having me on. I really appreciate it. You all take care. You do great to see you, man.
祝你今年夏天旅途愉快。大家都去看《宝石世家》，随时欢迎回来和我们聊天。谢谢，丹尼。非常感谢。谢谢邀请我来。我真的很感激。你们都保重。你也是，见到你真好，伙计。
All right. See you, too All right, bye. Bye. There's a guy who's never not funny. It's just me. I love everything he does. And sweet, sweet and funny. Will, wasn't it your handle in high school? Sweet and funny. Sweet and funny, yeah.
好吧。再见。好吧，再见。再见。那是个永远不会不搞笑的家伙。就是我。我喜欢他做的一切。而且甜美，甜美又搞笑。威尔，那不是你高中的绰号吗？甜美又搞笑。甜美又搞笑，是啊。
Funny, sweet. I'm also kind of like amazed, like that's why I asked that question earlier. I'm so amazed that when people do, I can't imagine like writing and showering and then being in it and like being good in it, like he is like, like Jason, like you are, like when you're Ozark, when you're directed
搞笑，甜美。我也感到有点惊讶，这就是为什么我刚才问那个问题。我非常惊讶，当人们做……我无法想象一边写剧本，一边洗澡，然后又参演，而且演得那么好，就像他一样，就像杰森，就像你一样，当你在《黑钱胜地》里，当你执导
the thing and then you just jump in front of the camera and act and brilliantly and, I mean, what part could he not play? What movie would you not want him in? He could do the comedy, do the drama. He could just write if you want him not on it. I know. Which he often does as well.
那部戏，然后你又跳到镜头前表演，而且非常出色，我是说，有什么角色是他演不了的？有什么电影你不想让他参演？他能演喜剧，能演正剧。如果你不想让他演，他还能写剧本。我知道。他经常这样做。
He would direct it. It's so, isn't that rare though? Yeah. It's a rare that somebody can, you can just pick up a pen right apart for yourself in a show that you created and then go make it. Yeah. And he does these shows for like three years at a time and then shuts it down and then starts a brand new one.
他还会执导。这不是很罕见吗？是啊。一个人能拿起笔为自己写一个角色，在自己创作的剧里，然后去把它拍出来，这很罕见。是啊。而且他一次做这些剧三年，然后关掉它，再开始一个全新的。
Yeah. I want to get into that line of work. I'd like to be his McGrroom. Oh. Wonderful. Anybody? Wonderful. Guys, I love you so much.
是啊。我想进入那一行。我想成为他的跟班。哦。太棒了。有人吗？太棒了。伙计们，我太爱你们了。
I love you. Are you just gonna say goodbye? We're just gonna say goodbye. Well, I gotta go bye-bye because I gotta go to this thing. Oh, cool. go to your thing. It's really great having seen you both today. Sean, you know I heard this show. By the way, you're going to do your play tonight.
我也爱你。你只是要说再见吗？我们只是要说再见。好吧，我得走了，再见，因为我得去参加那个活动。哦，酷。去参加你的活动吧。今天见到你们俩真是太好了。肖恩，你知道我听说了这个节目。顺便说一句，你今晚要演你的戏。
Again, you're doing a good job. What's it called, Will? It's called Good Night Oscar. And what theater is it at? And it's at the Chabasco. Chabasco. Chabasco. Chabasco.
再说一次，你做得很好。叫什么名字，威尔？叫《晚安，奥斯卡》。在哪个剧院？在查巴斯科。查巴斯科。查巴斯科。查巴斯科。
Chabasco theater. Oh, man. And by the way, Trabasco. Trabasco. Trabasco, theater. Oh, man. And by the way, it's been doing really well. Very well. And it's been sold out. And in fact, you can't even get a seat, but you can be put on. Stand by your man.
查巴斯科剧院。哦，伙计。顺便说一句，特拉巴斯科。特拉巴斯科。特拉巴斯科剧院。哦，伙计。顺便说一句，它一直演得很好。非常好。而且票都卖光了。事实上，你连座位都买不到，但你可以被列入候补名单。
Oh, nice. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
哦，不错。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness is 100% organic and artisantly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf. Smartness. Jeff. Smug. Loss. Rex Chapman. Hello.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智。聪明才智是由本内特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·昂杰夫100%有机且手工制作的。聪明才智。杰夫。自负。损失。雷克斯·查普曼。你好。
Hello, Rex. Hello, Will. Sean Jason. So great to be here. How was your going? Thank you. Wonderful to meet you. Thank you.
你好，雷克斯。你好，威尔。肖恩，杰森。很高兴来到这里。你怎么样？谢谢。见到你真是太好了。谢谢。
Thank you for talking with us. Yeah. So we got this new podcast with you called owned or very, very excited. You said yes to doing this. Thank you so much. I'm so grateful. You guys asked when they said that Rex Chapman was going to do a podcast with us. I said, how are we possibly going to do a podcast about moonshine? But you know what? They said it's not. It's not. Right. It's not that. It's not that. It's not that. Sports owners. But you are here today because of owned, which is a smartness media podcast that we're so lucky to have you. Yeah. So nice. You said yes to do that. I'm so thankful
谢谢你和我们交谈。是啊。所以我们和你有个新播客叫《拥有》（Owned），非常非常兴奋。你答应做这个。非常感谢。我太感激了。你们问的时候，当他们说雷克斯·查普曼要和我们一起做播客时。我说，我们怎么可能做一个关于私酿酒的播客？但你知道吗？他们说不是。不是。没错。不是那个。不是那个。不是那个。体育老板。但你今天在这里是因为《拥有》，这是一个聪明才智媒体的播客，我们很幸运能有你。是啊。太好了。你答应做那个。我太感谢了
you guys. It's fantastic. It's out now. Yeah. It's it's really, really great. Tell us briefly exactly like what what it what it is. And why is it- Talk to the dummies we are. Like maybe like a listener that has no idea what this is about. I'm gonna go. I know I'm gonna bring- Oh, okay, you ready? Now, talk to me now.
你们。太棒了。现在已经上线了。是啊。它真的真的很好。简要告诉我们它到底是什么。为什么它是……对我们这些笨蛋说。就像一个完全不知道这是关于什么的听众。我要走了。我知道我要带……哦，好吧，你准备好了吗？现在，跟我说说。
All right, here we go. So, you know how you guys with your movies or your TV shows, there's a finance here, a person who's paying the bills, footing the bill. Sometimes those guys, those women, people, they don't know anything about making a movie or a TV show. And I'm sure for you guys, that's pretty frustrating when that person wants to have say
好吧，我们开始吧。所以，你知道你们拍电影或电视节目时，会有财务人员，一个付账单的人，买单的人。有时那些家伙，那些女人，那些人，他们对制作电影或电视节目一窍不通。我敢肯定对你们来说，当那个人想要对
as to what's going on film. It can be a challenge. Well, you're looking at my track record. I don't know anything about making a movie or TV show. So let's be real. Let's call it what it is. But sports ownership is really no different. I mean, there are good owners and they're not so good owners.
电影里发生的事情指手画脚时，那会非常令人沮丧。这可能是一个挑战。好吧，你看看我的履历。我对制作电影或电视节目一窍不通。所以让我们现实一点。让我们直说吧。但体育所有权真的没什么不同。我是说，有好老板，也有不那么好的老板。
And there are bad owners. Most of them are millionaires to billionaires. And they do this for a hobby. Some are very good. Some of them have sports backgrounds. And those owners are usually pretty good to work for and play for. The others though are not just as you might imagine.
还有坏老板。他们大多数是百万富翁到亿万富翁。他们把这当作爱好。有些非常好。有些有体育背景。那些老板通常很好相处，也很好效力。但其他的，正如你所想象的那样，就不是了。
They were asking me earlier about some of the owners I had. I played for two owners. The first one was in Charlotte. And that was a guy named George Shin, and he was very cheap, didn't spend a lot. I remember a couple. We got the Transistra radio for Christmas one year, and a monogrammed Bible when he came alive.
他们早些时候问我关于我遇到的一些老板。我为两个老板效力过。第一个在夏洛特。那是个叫乔治·辛的家伙，他非常吝啬，不怎么花钱。我记得有几次。有一年圣诞节我们收到了晶体管收音机，还有他活过来时送的刻有名字的圣经。
Oh my God. Yeah, yeah. And so then I was traded from there and went to Washington and played for the old bullets. A. R. Bullen was the owner. And my first day there, I get to the locker room and we're practicing, we don't have a practice facility. It's at Bowie State University. And it's got a literal play stage on the side of the gym.
哦，天哪。是啊，是啊。然后我被交易了，去了华盛顿，为老子弹队效力。A.R.布伦是老板。我第一天到那里，我到了更衣室，我们在训练，我们没有训练设施。是在鲍伊州立大学。健身房旁边有一个真正的表演舞台。
It's a high school gym. But we're in there, I'm in there and there's a note school gym. Right. But we're in there. I'm in there and there's a note on my chair by my locker. Very first day and it asks me, says, you can take your gear home and wash it every day or you can pay, have $25 taken out of your check every week so we can pay the equipment manager to wash your shit for you.
那是一个高中健身房。但我们在那里，我在那里，我的储物柜椅子上有一张纸条。第一天，它问我，说，你可以每天把装备带回家洗，或者你可以付钱，每周从你的工资里扣25美元，这样我们就可以付钱给装备经理帮你洗你的东西。
Why? So it's a professional basketball, professional basketball team. What year was that? This was 1992. Did you have to drive yourself to away games? No, but we, but in Washington, you're not supposed to take buses and then be anything longer than an hour and a half. So you can travel like Philly to DC maybe.
为什么？所以这是一个职业篮球，职业篮球队。那是哪一年？那是1992年。你得自己开车去客场比赛吗？不，但是我们……在华盛顿，你不应该坐超过一个半小时的巴士。所以你可以去费城到华盛顿之类的。
Right. We traveled all over the East Coast on buses. No. Boston, New York, New Jersey to DC. And, you know, we'd play the next sometimes at home and then play them the next night in the garden and they would beat us home because they flew back after the game.
没错。我们坐巴士跑遍了整个东海岸。不。波士顿、纽约、新泽西到华盛顿。而且，你知道，我们有时在主场打完比赛，第二天晚上在花园球场打，他们会在比赛后飞回去，比我们先到家。
Sure. And we're driving up on a bus the next day. Wait, and you guys are, and you're not, how tall are you, Rex? Six, three, six, four. Right. So again, I mean, still by NBA standards, maybe not the tallest, but also very tall. Right. And the rest of your teammates, you probably had guys who were six, seven, six, eight,
当然。而我们第二天坐巴士赶过去。等等，你们是……你有多高，雷克斯？6英尺3英寸，6英尺4英寸。没错。所以，我是说，按照NBA标准，也许不是最高的，但也非常高。没错。而你的其他队友，你可能有6英尺7英寸、6英尺8英寸的家伙，
crammed on a bus. I mean, that's not good for the product. Yeah, it's not good. that's not good for the product. Yeah, it's not good. It's not good for the product. But that was, you know, that was an ownership that just didn't spin. I was traded though. I was traded though from there to Miami.
挤在一辆巴士上。我是说，这对产品不好。是啊，不好。这对产品不好。是啊，不好。这对产品不好。但那是，你知道，那是一个不花钱的老板。但我被交易了。我被交易了，从那里去了迈阿密。
The Miami Heat who are currently playing, or playing in the NBA finals. Yeah. Great ownership. Mickey Eris and got there. He was one of the first team owners to buy a plane We got a plane our first year so now we're not even flying commercial Which most other teams do yeah, we have our own plane and that changes the whole game and as you guys know to it's not just
迈阿密热火队，他们目前正在打，或者正在打NBA总决赛。是啊。伟大的老板。米奇·阿里森到了那里。他是第一批买飞机的球队老板之一。我们第一年就有了飞机，所以现在我们甚至不用坐商业航班，大多数其他球队都坐商业航班。是啊，我们有自己的飞机，这改变了整个游戏规则。而且正如你们所知，这不仅仅是
Spending on the top players, right? It's not just spending on the you know the the marquee actor It's spending on everybody and making everyone feel loved and valued and that's what the good owners do. I went on to Phoenix and played for Jerry Kalangelo, another great owner. So it just boils down to, you know, which owners are good, which owners are not. And the ones that aren't just kind of back off
在顶级球员身上花钱，对吧？不仅仅是在你知道的，大牌演员身上花钱。这是在每个人身上花钱，让每个人都感到被爱和被重视，这就是好老板所做的。我后来去了菲尼克斯，为杰里·科朗杰洛效力，另一个伟大的老板。所以归根结底，你知道，哪些老板好，哪些老板不好。那些不好的老板只会退后，
and let people do their jobs. And it's not just money. It's also just like, that trickle down effect vibe wise to the whole team is so important, right? From the ownership, no question. And you know, the owners that know your kids and your wife's name and you're, you know,
让人们做他们的工作。这不仅仅是钱的问题。这还关乎那种对整个团队的涓滴效应，对吧？从所有权开始，毫无疑问。而且你知道，那些知道你孩子和你妻子名字的老板，你知道，
you're the people that come to the game with you. The owners that, it's no different than life, relations. Yeah, that's what I like about it. Like it's no secret, I'm not a. Yeah, that's what I like about it. Like, it's no secret. I'm not a massive sports fan, but listening to this podcast owned, I'm like really into it because of what you just said, because I love the human stories. Right. And like, I'm really, really into how that all works.
那些和你一起去看比赛的人。那些老板，这和生活、关系没什么不同。是啊，这就是我喜欢它的地方。这不是什么秘密，我不是一个……是啊，这就是我喜欢它的地方。这不是什么秘密。我不是一个超级体育迷，但听这个播客《拥有》，我真的很投入，因为你刚才说的，因为我喜欢人类的故事。没错。而且，我真的很喜欢这一切是如何运作的。
And like, everything you just said, I think it's fascinating. I think you make a great point, Sean. And I probably should have said this. This isn't targeted for sports nuts. This is targeted for people that listen to your guys show who are entertainment people who love storytelling. And are gonna get some of these crazy owners. Yeah, by the way, Rex,
而且，你刚才说的每一件事，我觉得都很迷人。我觉得你提出了一个很好的观点，肖恩。我可能应该早点说。这不是针对体育迷的。这是针对听你们节目的那些娱乐界人士，他们热爱讲故事。而且会听到一些疯狂的老板的故事。是啊，顺便说一句，雷克斯，
so just speaking of sports nuts, did you wear a cup? No, I didn't, yeah, no, it's a good question. We do that. I think back and why didn't we wear cups, but you also rarely get hit in the balls and basketball. I wore one to high school just so I could feel a little more masculine. But it's fun to sort of vicariously live through these, these own, like how many, how many people said, say boy if I had $10 billion what would you do what would you buy you know and and so to hear about what these massively wealthy people do
说到体育迷，你戴护裆了吗？不，我没有，是啊，不，这是个好问题。我们确实那样。我回想起来，为什么我们不戴护裆，但在篮球比赛中你也很少被击中蛋蛋。我高中时戴过一个，只是为了让自己感觉更阳刚一点。但通过这些，像代理人一样生活，很有趣，有多少人说，如果我有100亿美元，你会做什么，你会买什么，你知道，所以听到这些极其富有的人用
with all of that influence and access and and permission. A lot of them do the right thing and a lot of them do the wrong thing and that's kind of some of the stuff you explore yeah. No question the good ones are always fun the bad ones are fun. For instance, we have Rick Riley on. Oh, yeah, I love it. And we did a, we have an episode on Marge Shot. Yeah, we know. Ask Marge Shot. Marge used to say the inward regularly. Wow. She was not, she let her dogs poop on riverfront stadium out there in the field. But Rick was telling us a story. He said, we asked him, you know, any just crazy weird story with Margie said, I don't know where to start, but he came up with one. He went to interview her at her house and she was off chasing the dog around. And he was kind of meandering through the halls. And
所有那些影响力和权限去做什么。很多人做了正确的事，很多人做了错误的事，这正是你们探索的一些东西。是啊，毫无疑问，好的总是很有趣，坏的也很有趣。例如，我们请来了里克·赖利。哦，是啊，我喜欢。我们做了一集关于玛吉·肖特的节目。是啊，我们知道。问玛吉·肖特。玛吉过去经常说那个N开头的词。哇。她不是，她让她的狗在河滨体育场的球场上拉屎。但里克在给我们讲一个故事。他说，我们问他，你知道，关于玛吉的任何疯狂奇怪的故事，他说，我不知道从哪里开始，但他想出了一个。他去她家采访她，她正忙着追狗。他就在大厅里漫步。然后她走回来，他从抽屉里拿出一个纳粹臂章。哦，哇。他问玛吉关于这个的事，她只是有点不屑一顾地说，哦，是啊，只是，你知道，抽屉里的东西。小纪念品。
She was off chasing the dog around, and he was kind of meandering through the halls, and she walks back, and he pulls out of a drawer, a Nazi arm band. Oh, wow. And he asks, smart, about this, and she just kind of poo-poo-sit and says, oh yeah, just, you know, just something in the drawer there. Little memorabilia.
小纪念品。什么？而这位女士多年来一直经营着辛辛那提红人队。我是说，看，这些就是你听不到的那种故事，没错。还有你们请过的其他嘉宾，拉里·威尔莫尔、保罗·谢尔、罗素·克劳、艾克·巴林霍尔茨，很多人都来了。太棒了。我不确定我是否想和你们一起做这个，因为通常我们只是，
Little memorabilia. What? And this lady was running the Cincinnati Reds for years and years and years. I mean, see, those are the kind of stories that you don't hear any like, right. And other guests that you've had on Larry Wilmore, Paul Sherr, Russell Crowe, Ike Baronholds, like a lot of people been coming on. It's fantastic. I wasn't sure I wanted to do this with you guys because normally we just,
我刚刚招待了奥斯卡奖得主。我们有罗素·克劳和娜塔莉·波特曼，对吧？是啊。你们中还没有人赢过奥斯卡，对吧？现在娜塔莉在说什么？他们没有给《米勒一家》颁奖。抱歉。继续，雷克斯。娜塔莉是一个足球队的一部分，对吧？娜塔莉，一个女子足球队。是的。洛杉矶天使
I had just entertained the, the Oscar winners. We've got Russell Crowe and Natalie Portman, right? Yeah. None of you guys have won Oscars yet. Have you? Now what's Natalie talking about? They didn't give them out for the millers on CBS. Sorry. Go ahead, Rex. Natalie's part of a soccer team, right? Natalie, a women's soccer team. Yes. The LA angel.
FC。哦，天使，天使，是的。而且，嗯，是一个合伙人，对吧？合伙人。他们有一大堆著名的演员、艺人、运动员拥有那支球队。这已经成了一件大事。而且他们，他们非常以使命为导向。他们试图，是的。抱歉。你应该，你应该和彼得·古伯谈谈。他是道奇队的合伙人，喜欢金州勇士队，对吧？还有哦，还有别的东西。我知道你有联系，因为你几乎不会错过一场道奇队的比赛，不是吗，杰森？嗯，我一年去大约20到30次。
FC. Oh, the angels, angels, yes. And, and, um, I mean, it's a partner, huh? Part owner. And they've got a ton of famous actors, entertainers, athletes that own that squad. And it's become a big deal. And they are, they're so mission oriented. They're trying to, yes. Sorry. You should, you should talk to Peter Goober. He's part owner of the Dodgers and love to Golden State Warriors, right? And oh, something else too. I know you've got a connection because you barely miss a Dodgers game, don't you, Jason? Well, I go to about 20 or 30 a year.
是啊，我爱他。你们三个小时候有认真参加过体育运动吗？我什么都玩一点，除了橄榄球。我母亲想让我踢足球，因为她是英国人。所以我从来没玩过橄榄球，但其他我都玩过，我很喜欢。我也玩了一点。我是说，我以非常平均的水平玩了所有东西，但我喜欢玩这些东西，而且我是一个超级体育迷。顺便说一句，你应该谈谈的另一个人是肖恩·海耶斯。他总是每个人。
Yeah, I love him. Did you guys play, did any of the three of you play sports seriously as a kid? I played everything a little bit except for football. My mother wanted me to play soccer because she was from England. So I never got to play football, but everything else I played, I loved. I played a little bit too. I mean, I played everything very average at a very average rate, but I loved playing stuff, and I'm a huge sports nut. The other guy you should talk to, by the way, is Sean Hayes. He's always everybody.
我们都做了同样的杰夫·汤姆。汤姆·华纳。哦，是啊。他是红袜队和利物浦足球俱乐部的合伙人，那是我的俱乐部，现在还有匹兹堡企鹅队。太棒了。他们会来的。你们把这些老板介绍给我们。
We all made the same Jeff Tom. Tom Warner. Oh, yeah. He's part owner of the Red Sox and Liverpool FC, which is my club and now the Pittsburgh penguins. Fantastic. They'll come on. You guys throw these owners our way.
你知道，这是一个聪明才智的事情。是啊，为了分享。肖恩，你玩什么？你上学时玩什么运动？你玩吗？你踢足球吗？我打棒球。我在伦斯队和路跑者队。伦斯队和路跑者队。是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。然后我玩了一年橄榄球。是啊。我会在，我会在，我不记得了，我想我打安全卫，我会在争球线上，对吧？我会在姿势里，你知道，四肢着地。而我对面的家伙不可避免地总是会说些什么，比如，我要干掉你。
You know, this is a smart one thing. Yeah, for's share. Sean, what did you play? What sports did you play in school growing up? You played? Did you play soccer? I played baseball. I was on the Rens and the Roadrunners. The Rens and the Roadrunners. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then I played football one year. Yeah. And I'd be in the, I'd be in the, I don't remember, I think I played a safety and I'd be in the Scrimmage line, right? And I'd be in the stance, you know, in all fours. And the guy across from me inevitably would always say something like, I'm going to fuck you up.
我要杀了你。我要，就像，你知道，我有点被搞糊涂了。我把它看得太个人化了，我会想，我真的什么都没对你做。你为什么要那样对我说话？我过去常常把它看得太个人化了，我会想，我真的什么都没对你做。你为什么要那样对我说话？我过去常常把它看得太个人化了。然后我只想去麦当劳或者喝免费的，你知道，汽水或苏打水。你知道那有什么好笑的吗？
I'm going to kill you. I'm going to, like, you know, I kind of get my head. And I would take it so personally, I'd be like, I literally have done nothing to you. Why would you speak to me that way? And I used to take it so personally, I'd be like, I literally have done nothing to you. Why would you speak to me that way? And I used to take it so personally. And then I would only want to go to the McDonald's or get like the free, you know, pop or soda ever. You know what's funny about that?
你从来没在比赛中途去过麦当劳，对吧？你知道那有什么疯狂的吗？大多数人参加体育运动只是为了好玩，为了和朋友一起做点什么，但有一个点，如果你真的想认真玩，你几乎必须得是个混蛋。这与我们教导孩子的一切背道而驰，培养孩子要有礼貌、友善、尊重、互相帮助，所有这些。不，在篮球场上不行。一旦你到了高中高年级，也许。但这不一样。你得有点混蛋。当我为路跑者队效力时，
You never went to McDonald's in the middle of the game, did you? You know what's crazy about that is as most of us play sports just to have fun and to do something with our friends and but there comes a point where if you're going to really play seriously, you almost have to be an asshole. And it's contrary to everything we teach our kids, raising kids to be polite, nice, respectful, help each other, all of that stuff. No, not on the basketball court. Once you get to senior at high school, maybe. But it's just different. You got to kind of be a jerk. When I played for the roadrunners,
我同时也在试镜广告。我走到本垒板前，教练以为他在给予真正的支持，比如，嘿，把它打出去。我是联合航空公司的广告。我为他试镜。把它一直打到联合航空公司。而我心想，你，把它打出去。哦，是联合航空公司的广告。我只是把它一直带到联合航空公司。而我心想，你没必要那样做。这真的很不错，但我只是想打球。
I was auditioning for commercials too at the same time. And I get up to the plate and the coach thought he was being real supportive of like, hey, he's hit that out. I was United Airlines commercial. I auditioned for him. Hit it all the way to United Airlines. And I'm like, you, hit that out. Oh, it's United Airlines commercial. I'll just bring it all away to United Airlines. And I'm like, you don't have to do that. It's really nice, but I'm just trying to hit the ball.
你很客气，但你没必要把这两者联系起来。嘿，雷克斯，新老板进来时，在警告信号方面有什么共同点吗？还有其他事情吗？警告信号方面有什么共同点吗？还有其他事情吗？不，球员，球员通常只是打球。但有趣的是，你总是能看出训练是，你知道，这有点像是你打卡上班，你在投入
It's very kind of you, but you don't have to relate the two. Hey, Rex, is there a common denominator in terms of warning signs with a new owner coming in that you got to look for? Is there other things? denominator in terms of warning signs with a new owner coming in that you got to look for. Is there other things? No, players, players normally just play. The funny thing though is that you can always tell practices are, you know, it's kind of your punching the clock, you're putting your
时间。别让老板走进训练场。老板走进训练场，一切都会提升一个或两个档次。每个人都打得更努力，想在老板面前表现出最好的一面。而且无论什么球队，什么特许经营权，如果老板走进训练场，你知道，你会有一场艰苦的训练，因为教练会逼你更努力。
time in. Don't let the owner walk into practice. The owner walks into practice, everything ratchets up a notch or two notches. Everybody plays harder, wants to put on their best face for the owner. And it doesn't matter what team, what franchise, if the owner walks into practice, you know, you're gonna have a hard practice, because the coach is gonna push you harder
时间到了。别让老板走进训练场。老板一旦走进训练场，一切都会升级一两个档次。每个人都会打得更卖力，想在老板面前表现出最好的一面。无论在哪支球队，哪个特许经营权，如果老板走进训练场，你知道，你将会迎来一场艰苦的训练，因为教练会逼你更努力。
and the players are gonna play hard. Yeah, it's a boss. The guy who signs the check comes in. I mean, I don't care if I'm sweeping in the corner of the boss walks in, I'm sweeping that twice the pace. That's exactly right. Especially if they got a Nazi arm band on. Yeah, that's gonna make you pick up the pace of you see
球员们会努力打球。没错，那是老板。发工资的人进来了。我的意思是，我不在乎我是否在角落里扫地，如果老板走进来，我扫地的速度会快两倍。完全正确。尤其是如果他们戴着纳粹臂章的话。是的，如果你看到那个，肯定会让你加快速度。
if you're fucking an actual Nazi. Turbo. Jesus. That is genius. Tronati. Turbo. Jesus. That. That is genius. Rack does get your attention. Rack Chapman. It's called owned. It is fun, funny, dynamic, surprising. You're great. The guests are great.
如果你是在为一个真正的纳粹工作。涡轮。天哪。那真是天才。特罗纳蒂。涡轮。天哪。那。那真是天才。雷克斯确实引起了你的注意。雷克斯·查普曼。这叫拥有。它很有趣、好笑、充满活力、令人惊喜。你很棒。嘉宾们也很棒。
We're so lucky to have you part of the smartness media family. Fair enough. God bless you. It's such a great show. I love it. Thanks so much for having me guys. Rex. I love you. Thank you. Love you guys. I'll see. Well, that's a man that can host a podcast clearly. Yeah. Yeah. Got a nice speaking voice. And he was a huge NBA star. And he understands the sport right from the inside. Uh-huh. Yeah. So you can, I mean, we're in good hands with him. It seems like, you know, I guess we could do. I don't know about you guys, but I never read his auto. Bye. Oh,
我们很幸运能让你成为Smartness Media大家庭的一员。说得好。上帝保佑你。这真是一个很棒的节目。我喜欢它。非常感谢你们邀请我。雷克斯。我爱你。谢谢。我也爱你们。我会见的。嗯，那是一个显然能主持播客的人。是的。是的。声音很好听。而且他曾经是一位伟大的NBA球星。他从内部了解这项运动。嗯哼。是的。所以你可以，我的意思是，我们有他在很放心。看起来，你知道，我想我们可以做。我不知道你们怎么想，但我从来没读过他的自传。哦，
agafate. We'll check out on out now wherever you get your podcasts. This episode was recorded on May 25th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered, as the King of Pop or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn.
现在就在你获取播客的地方收听吧。本集录制于5月25日。我们的下一集将在下周发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，也可以通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry应用中的Wondry Plus提前收听且无广告。自2009年去世以来，世界一直在纠结该如何纪念迈克尔·杰克逊，是作为流行音乐之王，还是作为一个怪物。我是莱昂·内法克，《Fiasco》的主持人，《Slow Burn》的联合创作者。
And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator. Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancellable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art.
我是杰伊·斯穆斯，一位嘻哈记者和文化评论员。迈克尔·杰克逊在1993年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思而后行：迈克尔·杰克逊》讲述了在那之前和之后发生的故事。在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊看起来无法被“取消”。当我们走进杂货店听到《Billie Jean》时，我们深入挖掘了许多人内心复杂的感受。通过对亲眼目睹这一故事发展的人们进行的数十次原创采访，《三思而后行》试图调和我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这个人的矛盾情绪，以及我们对他艺术的深沉热爱。
Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music app. wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在任何你获取播客的地方收听《三思而后行：迈克尔·杰克逊》，或者你可以在Audible或Amazon Music应用上无广告地一口气听完整个系列。在任何你获取播客的地方收听，或者你可以在Audible或Amazon Music应用上无广告地一口气听完整个系列。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。